[Musique]
bienvenue à tous tous pour cette
conférence débat qui s'annonce
honnêtement passionnante au tour de jean
marc jancovici que je remercie vivement
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
cette conférence débat organisée par le
cercle vulnérabilité société et ça elle
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un site de
réflexion autour du rôle et de la place
des personnes les plus vulnérables dans
le monde de demain qui va être marquée
par le dérèglement climatique et la
raréfaction des ressources un cycle
d'air que nous avions ouvert il ya
quelques mois avec gail geron alors
avant de présenter à notre invité comme
il se doit et pour celles et ceux qui ne
me connaissent pas le cercle finalité
société il s'agit d'un groupe de
réflexion et d'action qui est composé de
45 organisations privées publiques et
associatives qui travaillent de manière
transversale sur les vulnérabilités du
champ social et de la santé
plus particulièrement en oeuvre en fait
à identifier les conditions qui vont
permettre de valoriser la contribution
des personnes dites vulnérables dans
notre société
qu'elles soient en situation de handicap
de perte d'autonomie malades en deuil et
précaires en situation des danses etc
donc merci aux membres du cercle pour
leur présence sur ce plateau merci à eux
et merci à l'ensemble des personnes qui
nous suivent en direct puisque au delà
de ce plateau virtuel la conférence
débat est également ouverte à tous
voix il y aura l'air évidemment un
replay je laisse maintenant la parole à
thierry calvat et le soin de vous
présenter charge jean marc jancovici est
aussi peut-être de resituer pour tous le
thème de notre intervention et le cadre
de notre réflexion à toi thierry merci
bonjour et bonsoir plus exactement jean
marc jancovici et de fait c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on a le plaisir de recevoir
celui qu aurélien bélanger qualifié
récemment d'intellectuels dominant sur
france culture avec une pointe de regret
donc de sincérité un intellectuel dans
la lecture physique du monde rappelle à
tous ceux qui l'écoutent que les fai
auront toujours raison sur l'opinion et
pour ceux qui vous connaîtraient pas
encore il y en a vous êtes ingénieur en
énergie engagée contre le réchauffement
climatique mais aussi enseignant auteur
conférence sié fondateur et président du
sim tente de chiffres project membre du
haut conseil pour le climat mais aussi
encore promoteurs et développeur de
bilan carbone et accessoirement pour
ceux qui vous connaissent mieux c'est ce
que vous êtes celui qui est annoncé avec
5 à 7 ans d'avancé la crise des gilet
jaune à des parlementaires médusé
l'ordre de au moins une ou deux
auditions parlementaires et au moment où
le récent rapport du giec vient
renforcer encore un peu plus ce que vous
dites depuis plus de 20 ans à une
communauté grandissante d'étudiants de
décideurs et parfois même de politique
ne semblait plus qu intéressant d'avoir
un éclairage votre éclairage sur un
sujet qui reste généralement sous la
ligne de radars des réflexions touchant
au vieillissement au handicap à la
maladie ou à la précarité et ce sujet
c'est celui des influences de la dérive
équipés de la contraction prévisible des
ressources sur la façon d'envisager
demain la vulnérabilité dans un monde
dont on pressent la transformation à
venir qu'elle soit voulue aux forcés et
elle serait d'ailleurs semble-t-il
plutôt forcé comme on a eu l'occasion de
le voir à l'occasion de l'épisode de
lakovic 19 quels sont les risques mais
aussi les opportunités pour les
populations les plus vulnérables
à quel type d'arbitrage a maintenant
être appelé surtout si demain nous
sommes confrontés à des situations de
pénurie de plus en plus fréquentes et
votre propos est d'autant plus important
que ce genre de contraintes figure
rarement dans les postulats de départ
des dernières productions public to
think tank confondues et qui
interviennent dans ce domaine et dont
les actions proposées se situe
généralement dans un cadre de pensée en
perpétuelle expansion derrière l'idée de
vulnérabilité se cache en effet rarement
l'idée d'une limite dans la façon de les
prendre en compte donc par avance merci
d'éclairer nos travaux et nommant contre
la façon d'être réaliste de façon
enthousiaste plutôt que
déraisonnablement utopique et après
cette introduction désespère n'avoir pas
fait trop longue je vous laisse la
parole alors pas précisées
pardonnez moi peut-être préciser le
temps de parole non c'était d'aller
convenu une quarantaine de minutes je
sais pas si c'est ce que vous aviez
n'avait jamais prévu un peu plus long
mais
je peux essayer de faire plus court
l'idée c'est à dire qu'en fait le
problème de genre de présentation c'est
que les malentendus vont se nicher dans
tout ce qui n'a pas été dit
attendez change évidemment un peu et je
j'entends bien
à partir du moment où vous faites vous
fait une présentation qui explique que
le monde de demain sera plus dur que le
monde d'hier
j'insiste les malentendus nous sommes
tous câblé pour avoir un réflexe de
dénis en pareil cas et à ce moment les
malentendus vont toujours se nicher dans
ce qui n'a pas été dit donc c'est pour
ça que j'aime bien faire des
présentations qui sont un peu et à l'est
mais bon je vais essayer de l'api par
ailleurs sadc des sujets un peu
technique même si ils ont des enjeux
majeurs et souvent les gens sont pas
familiers font venir adapco horrible qui
s'appelle la physique la chimie les
maths la biologie et après comme ça qui
rappelle des mauvais souvenirs en plein
de gens
voilà donc ces
jeux je
vais essayer de m'adapter
[Musique]
alors voilà
comme je sais que j'ai mon temps est
compté je vais commencer par la fin
la fin c'est que ce qui aujourd'hui nous
donne les moyens de prendre soin de tous
les gens qui n'ont pas ce qu'il faut
soit qu'ils soient dans le besoin soit
qu'ils soient vieux soit qu'ils soient
handicapés sûr qu'il soit malade sûr
qu'ils ne gagnent pas encore leur vie
parce qu'ils sont étudiants soit qu'ils
ne la gagne plus parce qu'ils sont
retraitées soit qu'il soit en prison
enfin bref tous les gens qui sont pas
productifs ce qui nous donne les moyens
aujourd'hui de leur donner à manger et
de les héberger même mal quand ils sont
en prison
récompenses d'aller en prison
on le doit au fait que
la quantité totale de moyens à notre
disposition ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
le pib je vais essayer de montrer que
c'est une réponse directe de la quantité
totale d'énergie qu'on a mobilisé donc
il ya un sous jacent physique sur
lesquels on a de la prise mais pas
complètement fait pas exactement ce
qu'on veut
qui est l'énergie à notre disposition et
que pour notre plus grand malheur cette
énergie aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'on
s'en sert elle conduit à des émissions
de co2 même en france alors je vais
retrouver qu'en finale
même en france est globalement dans le
monde et donc le drame de la faire
aujourd'hui c'est que prendre en charge
une personne handicapée ou soigner un
petit vieux ça émet du co2 et qu'on sait
pas faire autrement
alors si je l'écris en français ça
revient à dire ça ceux qui pilotent le
premier facteur limitant de l'économie
depuis deux siècles c'est la quantité
d'énergie à notre disposition et cette
quantité d'énergie à notre disposition
et mais proportionnellement depuis 50
ans du co2 c'est ça le drame de la
sphère en
alors maintenant je vais essayer de
devant entrer un peu plus dans le détail
d'abord je vais vous montrer par l'image
que la première égalité n'est pas vaine
ici vous avez un graphique dans lequel
depuis 1965 jusqu'en 2020 ça suit de
vous avez le regroupement des locaux
vides j'ai mis en abscisse la quantité
d'énergie qu'on mobilise dans le monde
et en ordonnée le pib mondial en dollars
constants
est ce que vous constatez c'est que au
premier ordre vous avez une droite alors
une droite qui est légèrement incurvé
parce qu'on fait un peu d'efficacité
énergétique au cours du temps mais en
gros vous avez une droite puis si vous
avez le reprendre rebroussement duo
qu'ovide donc il ya un truc qui marche
très très bien pour faire des grosses
d'économie d'énergie c'est pas ralentir
l'économie et vous voyez que rien du
reste ne fonctionne c'est à dire qu'à
aucun moment vous avez le pib qui a
augmenté avec l'énergie qui ne mentait
pas auquel cas la croix bord du sme est
à se balader par là ça n'est jamais
arrivé en ce qui concerne le monde dans
son ensemble
la deuxième chose la deuxième partie de
l'égalité c'est que plus on utilise
d'énergie plus on aimait de co2 donc ici
vous avez les émissions de co2 liées à
l'utilisation d'énergies et ici vous
avez la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
eh bien vous voyez car là pour le coup
depuis 1965 c'est rigoureusement droit
encore donc vous ne voyez pas dans cette
courbe le développement des nerfs vous
voyez pas plus ce développement du
nucléaire ont volé peu plus le
développement de l'hydroélectricité
tout ça s'est fait en même temps que les
fossiles continuer d'augmenter et donc
ce que vous voyez sur cette courbe c'est
quoi alors là c'est vraiment avec un
coefficient de régression match
frustrant spectaculaire
la quantité de co2 qu'on crache dans
l'eure est une fonction idr de la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise dans le
monde
très présent et alors du coup voici le
drame des négociations climat je ne
pense pas que glasgow va changer quoi
que ce soit sans vous voyez là dessus
que les négociations climat passé non
pas du tout changé ce qui s'est passé
depuis 1965 jusqu'en 2020 si je mets
d'un côté les émissions de co2
planétaire et de l'autre côté le pib
mondial
nouveau j'ai quelque chose qui est une
quasi droite c'est à dire qu'à chaque
fois que j'augmente le pib augmente les
émissions et pour augmenter le pib va
augmenter les émissions ce qui est une
autre manière de dire et je vais
conclure mon intervention par là où il
aurait commencé donc s'il ya des gens
pressés qu'ils peuvent partir tout de
suite
c'est que
aujourd'hui je n'ai jamais vu de calcul
probant
expliquant comment on allait respecter
l'accord de paris sans provoquer une
récession soutenues pendant des
décennies sur la planète j'ai jamais vu
ça je n'ai jamais vu de scénarios
probants qui permettent de dire qui
permettent de dire comment on va
concilier les deux l'explication
intermédiaire passe par suis pas en
train de faire le supporteur électorale
de tel ou tel candidat l'explication
intermédiaire passe par de la physique
alors
[Musique]
alors je vais en parlant de physique je
vais commencer par essayer d'expliquer
quand on regarde la machine économique
en fait ce qu'on compte est ce qu on ne
compte pas et à quels types de flux ça
correspond alors voici la planète terre
tels que je peux la synthétiser si je
suis un enfant de 2 ans dont 16 enfants
de 2 ans ils ont du mal à faire des
ronds et a décidé les continents donc un
enfant de deux ans pourrait décider la
planète terre comme ça c'est un grand
carré mais en fait c'est un grand carré
qui a deux compartiments en vision
anthropocentrique vu des êtres humains
c'est des ressources qu'on peut utiliser
alors on peut utiliser le sol pour
marcher dessus l'eau pour maje et dans
l'air pour le respirer
le sol pour le cultiver ça c'est des
ressources et aux ses ressources les
mets en deux catégories celles qui sont
renouvelables à l'échelle d'une vie
humaine par exemple l'herbe ou les
poissons et puis elle se renouvelle tout
de suite tout seul
et puis les ressources qui sont pas
renouvelables à l'échelle d'une vie
humaine par exemple la sole cultivée
ragoussis le sol cultivable sans vardon
pour refaire un sol cultivable il faut
attendre des centaines de milliers
d'années à partir de la roche ça c'est
pas renouvelables à l'échelle d'une vie
humaine par exemple du pétrole sameh 5 à
500 millions d'années pour se faire donc
à l'échelle d'une vie humaine c'est ce
que nouvelle pas par exemple du minerai
de fer une fois qu'on l'a sorti de terre
maïs renouvelle pas de génération
spontanée de minerai de fer batteur et
c'est donc là dedans on va trouver les
minerais les hydrocarbures et les
éléments de géographie
également on va trouver le système
climatique n'attend pas trop les garçons
semblent alors la convention économique
je n'y reviendrai pas plus loin dans cet
exposé mais je veux dire maintenant
postule que tout ça c'est gratuit alors
c'est gratuit mais pourtant ça a demandé
la mise en oeuvre de moyens qui
dépassent l'entendement et qui dépasse
de très loin nos possibilités c'est
indispensable à nos activités
économiques c'est par exemple si on n'a
pas de sol pour construire le bâtiment
pas de sol pour habiter si on avait une
planète totalement liquide par exemple
eh bien nous n'existerions pas l'ignorer
jamais une vie terrestre la planète
était totalement liquide donc sans sol
n'y a pas de pib mais vous ne trouverez
nulle part dans les comptes des
entreprises l'existence du solde
n'existe pas s'il y avait pas 20%
d'oxygène dans l'air il va pas de pib
non plus si on a une à une atmosphère
fait totalement base hot par exemple on
pourrait pas respirer on aurait tout ce
dont j'aurais pas de pib mais vous ne
trouvez dans aucun compte d'entreprises
le fait qu'ils aient 20% d'oxygène dans
l'air d'une manière générale les
ressources naturelles sont toutes
gratuites par convention et l'existence
des carrières du minerai de cuivre du
pétrole et des espèces naturelles tout
ça est gratuit c'est gratuit mais c'est
vrai quand même demandé énormément de
travail pour être fait par le nôtre
puisque il a fallu attendre 14 milliards
d'années d'évolution depuis le big bang
pour que on est la planète terre c'est
prendre l'avis de sucer 30 millions
d'espèces un système climatique des
océans démons dernière et l'échangé
lisez donc tout ça enfin où le sol puis
exactement pour construire les champs
elysées donc tout ça est gratuit et
pourtant indispensable alors les hommes
dans cette histoire ils vont faire les
hommes et les femmes vont avoir une
activité productive et cette activité
productive elle consiste à prélever les
ressources dans l'environnement et à les
transformer pour faire autre chose alors
avant de faire des machines à café
nespresso et autres iphone indispensable
on a fait des trucs totalement futile et
inutile comme descartes d'ail et des
pagnes des harpons et les pièges à
mammoth alors le principe est toujours
le même on prend des ressources dans
l'environnement et on les transforme dès
lors qu'on prend des ressources dans
l'environnement les non renouvelables
voient leurs stocks diminuer et que vous
prenez des silex dans l'environnement
pour les tailles et le stock de silex
non taillés dans l'environnement diminue
parekh ou paléolithique qui a eu
localement des pénuries de silex taillés
un spécialiste de la période
à l'époque la mondialisation du siècle
ce n'est pas bien donc vous avez un vous
avez ici les stocks non renouvelable qui
diminue des concerts par contre à cette
époque là enfin au moment de début de
l'activité productive les ressources
renouvelables continuent à avoir un flux
de renouvellement qui dépasse le fût de
prélèvements humains dont le stock
restent constants
et puis un jour les hommes découvrent
l'énergie alors j'y reviendrai
longuement dans cet exposé l'énergie en
fait est un moyen de démultiplier sa
propre action j'y reviendrai derrière et
donc quand on accède à l'énergie on peut
mettre en route des convertisseurs qui
vont suppléer qui vont qui vont qui vont
nous augmenter l'homme augmenté donc
c'est très très vieux mais depuis qu'on
a des nervis et ça permet d'augmenter le
sud prélèvements dans l'environnement et
de transformer plus marrant du coup on
diminue aussi des stocks plus vite dès
qu'on utilise de l'énergie les stocks de
toute nature qui ne se renouvelle pas
diminue plus vite et puis on a également
compris que l'on pouvait utiliser la
production passée pour augmenter la
production future c'est ce qu'on appelle
le capital donc en fait c'est les choses
qu'ils se détruisent pas quand on s'en
sert et qu'on peut utiliser pour
augmenter la production future
alors tout ça est parfait je ne sais pas
si c'est parce qu'on lit la bible mais
en tout cas on croit en se multiplient
et on devient de plus en plus nombreux
et individuellement on a un parc de
machines à notre disposition permettant
de prélever de transformer qui augmente
et donc on devient on accélère la
prédation sur l'environnement alors le
stock rhône où le stock non
renouvelables diminue de plus en plus
vite et puis un jour on devient
tellement nombreux et tellement
productif que même les stocks
initialement renouvelables commence à
baisser aussi
donc aujourd'hui par exemple le stock de
forêt est très inférieur à ce qu'il
était il ya quelques siècles le stock de
poisson est très inférieur à ce qu'il
était il ya quelques décennies voilà
vous avez un certain nombre de stocks
comme ça qu'ils sont en train de baisser
le stock d'espèces vivantes on n'en
parle pas les oiseaux les poissons les
mammifères les insectes tout ça est en
train de s'effondrer
et tout ça est lié à la prédation de
l'homme dans son environnement ou à des
sous produits indésirables de notre
activité
qu'on a coutume d'appeler la pollution
et qui vont eux diminuer la qualité des
actifs naturels résiduelles encore donc
la pollution ça vient diminuer donc là
je vous ai fait un petit diagramme dans
lequel je vous montre à quoi ressemble
physiquement j'ai toujours parlé d' euro
dollar ou 2 livres dans cette histoire
groupe i un petit diagramme qui vous
montre à quoi ressemble les flux
physiques qui sous tendent l'activité
productive des êtres humains et on a
décidé conventionnellement que
l'économie qu'on allait regarder c'est
juste ça donc en fait on va regarder
juste le flux de transformation et plus
ou plus exactement la contrepartie
monétaire associés au travail des hommes
et aux rentes des hommes liés à la
transformation donc en fait on ne va
même pas compter la transformation qu'on
aurait pu compter avec des
kilowattheures rodez joue le physicien a
droit de faire ça on compte juste la
contribution humaine dans la
transformation des ressources naturelles
donc quand vous achetez un verre là par
exemple j'ai un leurre
et bien quand j'achète sauvayre j'achète
tout sauf le verre les atomes de ce ver
je ne les paye pas ils ont été donnés
gratuitement par la nature les atomes
qui ont fait le four à verre des atomes
de fer personne ne les a payées non plus
nous ont été donnés gratuitement par la
nature donc en achetant ce ver je paye
les salaires et des rentes cumulé qui
vont des ressources naturelles
permettant de faire ce verre jusqu'au
vert je paye des hommes je ne paye pas
la nature qui ne m'a jamais réclamé de
factures alors évidemment avec ce type
de comptabilité plus il ya des hommes
qui se font payer et on se dit plus
avant plus le pull plus le plus voilà
alors il se trouve que ça aussi été
associée à une augmentation des flux de
prélèvement est donc en fait plus à bah
oui c'est une manière de dire que si
vous dilapidez d'héritage de vos parents
en allant en augmentant votre train de
vie
si je ne regarde que votre train de vie
ça va mieux si je suis une comptabilité
actif passif vous êtes en train de tout
dilapidé et en fait on aurait pu faire
une comptabilité actif passif sur la
planète on aurait pu dire quand je crée
quelque chose le compte en plus quand je
détruis quelque chose je le conte en
moins et le jour où la valeur marginale
du dernier immeuble que j'ai construit
est inférieur à la valeur marginale des
dernières carrière que j'ai détruit
quelque part en prélevant ce qu'il ya
dedans et des dernières mines de fer que
j'ai entre guillemets est détruite aussi
en prenant ce qu'il ya dedans des
dernières mines de charbon que j'ai
détruite parce qu'il faut de l'acier
pour faire des bâtiments donc le jour où
l'immeuble vaut moins cher que les
ressources que j'ai détruites pour
construire l'immeuble à ce moment je
n'arrête de faire des immeubles et je
vis happily ever after avec les
immeubles existants
donc dans une comptabilité actif passif
il ya évidemment un sous jacent
malthusien très fort par construction
parce que ça pose une limite au-delà de
laquelle on ne peut plus aller
la comptabilité que nous avons choisi de
faire elle est par construction sans
limite c'est à dire car aucun moment la
théorie économique dit quand le pib
mondiale atteindra 100 mille 362
milliards de dollars
on s'arrête pib s'arrête il n'y a pas ça
pour la théorie du coup les économistes
peuvent dire que ça va croître
indéfiniment parce que la théorie a
prévu un truc sans limite ils peuvent
effectivement mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ça va arriver en fait ça ne pourra
pas croître indéfiniment simplement la
théorie ne permet pas de le voir arriver
parce qu'elle a été construite pour ne
pas permettre de voir arriver donc à un
moment on aura de moins en moins de
moyens et à ce moment les économistes
expliquerons que c'est parce que on a
trop de charges passées de charges trop
d'impôts passer d'un projet par quoi en
fait la raison de fond c'est que la
physique soient en train de caler mais
j'y reviendrai un peu plus tard parce
qu'on en est déjà là
donc dans cette affaire il ya quelque
chose qui est absolument déterminant je
lui ai dit en introduction qui est
l'énergie alors je vais pas vous faire
un grand courbe physique sur l'énergie
dit même passé en revue toutes les
interprétations erronées de l'énergie je
fais ça parfois là on va aller
directement aux résultats avoir
l'énergie c'est ça vous avez ici une
incarnation physique de ce qu'est
l'énergie l'énergie c'est la bibine
d'iron man c'est la nourriture de cette
chose là alors sauf que là et rodman
qu'on utilise il n'a pas cette forme
mais il en a la même fonction
l'aéro de man qu'on utilise nous il a
c'est peut-être là voilà c'est ça iron
man pour nous sauf que c'est pas
vraiment encore que un costume qu'on
enfile le matin qui fait qu'à clac clac
qu'on repose sur le crochet sur la
patère à l'entrée le soir et qui est
alimenté par la lumière blanche au bio
mais c'est pareil vous voyez le petit
doigt gauche d'iron man là c'est surtout
et clara qui démultiplie la puissance de
son conducteur par 10000 la main droite
d'iron man c'est ça qui démultiplie la
puissance d'un homme par dix à cinquante
mille son oeil gauche c'est ça qui doit
évidemment beaucoup plus loin que nous
sa mâchoire c'est ça qui permet
d'écraser n'ont en l'occurence c'est un
four à verre donc c'est à sa mâchoire
ça c'est son pied gauche qui court
beaucoup beaucoup plus vite qu iron man
la mâchoire elle et la voilà qui permet
d'écraser absolument n'importe quoi ça
c'est les incisif qui permet de dérouler
du bois vrille et donc c'est iron man
que nous avons ici qui nous permet de
voler d'écraser de porter de transporter
beaucoup plus puissamment qu'avec nos
sols muscles et donc le parc de machines
dans le monde et iron man en pièces
détachées et l'énergie de ce parc de
machines et bien c'est la nourriture de
ces machines l'énergie c'est des
croquettes pour machines donc en fait
plus on consomme d'énergie plus on
consomme de croquettes pour machines et
plus en fait on peut domestique et de
machines qui vont travailler pour nous
c'est ça l'énergie c'est la puissance
des nations
en fait si on fait un des petits calculs
on se rend compte que chacune des
machines qu'on utilise est totalement
surpuissante par rapport à nos propres
risques alors si dans l'assistance il ya
des gens qui cet été on fait comme les
guides qui sont venus manifester à
l'assemblée la l'ascension du mont blanc
et en une seule journée quand vous
partez de chamonix le matin et
évidemment sans prendre le téléphérique
de l'aiguillé
vous partez pédibus coup j'en vis de
chamanique et vous monter au sommet du
mont blanc dans la journée et bien si
vous faites ça vos jambes vont fournir
une puissance moyenne de 100 watts
pendant l'exercice que vous faites il
n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
capables de faire ça et vous regardez
que si quelqu un paletot de la terre
toute la journée en fait vous allez vous
rendre compte que la puissance moyenne
des bras dans une journée c'est encore
moins que ça c'est dit what alors
maintenant vous prenez un mixeur à soupe
premier premier des trucs venu sera
souple un mixeur assoupi les puissants
comme quatre paires de jambes donc au
moment où vous appuyez sur le bouton de
votre mixeur à soupe vous avez 4
domestique qui se mettent à pédaler pour
vous mais c'est pas le même prévient si
vous utilisez un aspirateur l'acédie
personnes qui se mettent à pédaler pour
vous si vous appuyez sur un bouton
d'ascenseur ses cinquante personnes qui
se mettent à pédaler pour vous si vous
montez dans un tracteur ses 600 paires
de jambes qui se mettent à sanctionner
quand vous appuyer sur l'accélérateur si
vous montez dans un engin de travaux
publics qui font du terrassement fait
plutôt ça avec les bras là vous
démultiplier votre puissance par 10000
en dix mille fois les paires de bras
quand vous montez dans un camion s'est à
nouveau quelques milliers cette fois ci
c'est des paires de jambes et si vous
prenez un laminoir industriels et bien
un seul laminoir industriels développent
la même puissance que la totalité des
bras de la moitié de la population
active du privé en france donc si je
voulais remplacer un laminoir par des
gens papin sur des tôles avec des
marteaux pour laminer de la tôle et bien
j'aurai besoin d'affecter à cette
fonction la moitié de la population
active dans le privé dans ce pays pour
juste un laminoir qui
pilotait en continu par une personne
elle est maintenue par quelques
centaines donc voilà un tout petit
ensemble de notre costume d'iron man
évidemment des machines y en a des
dizaines des centaines des millions de
machines différentes qui sont toutes en
train de bosser pour nous et si je
regarde quelle est la puissance cumulée
de toutes ces machines à l'instant où je
vous parle là avec leur bibine qui leur
est particulière elle était multipliée
la puissance musculaire de l'humanité
par deux sens
et en france on est plutôt à x 600 ce
que je suis en train de vous dire je
vais maintenant traduire en termes
économiques ça veut dire qu'en france
pour avoir la même production économique
que celle que nous avons aujourd'hui si
nous n'avions pas de machine il faudrait
que la population française soit 600
fois plus nombreuses bon ça poserait
quelques petits problèmes des espaces
déjà aujourd'hui on commence à trouver
qu'on est un peu à l'étroit à certains
endroits donc là on aurait quand même un
petit sujet et dans le monde il faudrait
qu'on soit 200 fois plus nombreux pour
avoir la même production économique
c'est-à-dire d'allemagne capacité à
prélever des ressources dans
l'environnement elle est transformée
pour en faire des produits et des
services parce que même un service
demande des flux physiques d'envoyer par
exemple en ce moment où on pourrait
considérer que ce que je suis en train
de faire est un service de formation à
peu près ce que je suis en train de
faire sauf que ce service n'existerait
pas si j'avais pas un ordinateur une
demi tonne de co2 pour être fabriqué des
réseaux entre vous et moi de la
production électrique pour alimenter ses
réseaux vos propres terminaux parce que
vous n'êtes pas en train de me regarder
sur une feuille de papier et c'est donc
en fait le service que je suis en train
d'assurer en ce moment ils demandent des
flux physiques sous jacents pour pouvoir
être assuré et il n'y a pas un service
est pas un produit dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui qui échappe aux machines à
pains
donc si on n'avait pas les machines le
pib français serait divisé par 6 envoie
la suivante manière de dire la même
chose alors pas exactement par six ans
parce que c'est une règle de premier
ordre mais il serait / entre 50 et 100
oui ça c'est à peu près ça et on
n'aurait pas les moyens d'entretenir les
nécessiteux et du reste c'est très
exactement ce qui se passait dans
l'ancien temps dans l'ancien temps quand
la production française était
essentiellement agricole les gens penser
à se nourrir quelques je suis quelques
table quelques chaises et 3 double
qu'ils allaient fiesta et bien les
nécessiteux il avait la vie très très
dur il n'y avait pas beaucoup de monde
dans les prisons parce qu'on pouvait pas
nourrir les bouches inutiles dont on
comprend mais les gens ont les envoyés
aux galères il envoyait propulsion des
navires de guerre il n'y avait pas
d'études longues il y avait pas de
retraite il n'y avait pas les 35 heures
il y avait pas les week-ends il n'y
avait pas les congés payés tout ça
n'existait pas parce que en fait ce qui
a augmenté la productivité du travail
c'est la jonction des machines aux gens
c'est pas qu'on ait des bras et des
jambes qui nous ait poussé on n'est pas
devenu shiva on n'est pas devenu
n'avait pas à 52 paires de bras vous
n'en avez toujours qu'une seule
aussi du reste est toujours pour pousser
le bouchon encore aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des métiers que nous avons
sont des options des métiers
d'auxiliaire de machines c'est à dire
que si mon ouvrier des travaux publics
je suis capable de greffe et sa cervelle
directement là dessus je peux lui couper
ses bras ses jambes il fait le même
métier il n'y a pas de problème je n'ai
plus besoin pour l'ouvrier les travaux
publics qui manipulent ça en fait je
n'ai pas besoin de ses bras et de ses
jambes j'ai juste de rejoindre sa
cervelle c'est également vrai pour le
conducteur de train c'est également vrai
pour l'opérateur de satellites également
vrai pour le conducteur du camion c'est
également vrai pour le capitaine du
bateau tous ces gens-là n'utilise que
leur cervelle encore une fois si je suis
capable de greffer des cervelles est
certes un démiurge en rêve avec
l'intelligence artificielle et bien je
n'ai plus besoin de bras deux jambes
donc je donc l'énergie encore une fois
c'est la nourriture de cet ensemble
surpuissant qui nous a permis de vider à
vitesse accélérée les ressources
planétaires et de produire à vitesse
accélérée des produits transformés et on
a l'habitude de ne compter que les
produits transformés sans se soucier du
fait qu'on vit des placards bien
évidemment ne pas durer éternellement
alors cette énergie on trouve ça
vachement bien on trouve ça vachement
bien de vider les placards très vite on
trouve ça très bien de transformer
quelque chose nous sommes des animaux
accumulatif sans limite quand on a une
voiture on en veut deux quand on a deux
voitures on veut un jet privé quand on
gagne 1 milles on veut gagner 2000 et
quand on est de mise on veut gagner 4000
et quand on gagne un million on veut
gagner 2 donc le
la limite est un truc qu'on ne connaît
pas c'est parce qu'il était est du reste
il ya des gens qui explique que ça
renvoie aux structures privées est il de
notre cerveau et donc contrairement à
slogan bien connu la meilleure énergie
n'est pas celle qu'on ne consomme pas la
meilleure énergie est bien celle qu'on
consomme parce que ça permet d'augmenter
le nombre d'esclaves domestique descat
mécanique pardon que nous avons à
disposition et donc de satisfaire des
désirs qu'on n'avait pas avant voilà on
n'avait pas les jeux la virtualité jeu
pourquoi et c'est maintenant ou là en
plus de tout le reste et puis on ira
dans l'espace parce que monsieur besoin
c'est ses limites et comme il ya pas de
l'élite plus on a des énergies à
disposition plus on en consomme et c'est
très exactement ce que vous ayez sur ce
graphique et vous voyez que absolument
aucune des évolutions parfois avancés
par un certain nombre de gens pour se
rassurer en fait un
dix ans mais grâce à ça on va en
consommer moins aujourd'hui n'a permis
de consommer moins d'énergie on a
organisé la population très bien ça fait
pas consommer moins d'énergie on a
tertiarisée d'emplois ça fait pas
consommer moins d'énergie on a fait le
digital ça fait pas consommer moins
d'énergie rien ne nous fait consommer
moins d'énergie pour le moment tout
simplement parce qu'on empile des trucs
les uns sur les autres on les substituts
pas et on empile aussi les énergies des
unes sur les autres comme vous pouvez le
constater sur ce graphique alors vous
pouvez constater un autre chose sur ce
graphique c'est que là
l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui c'est les énergies fossiles
chacune d'entre elles prises
individuellement elle a augmenté encore
donc il ya pas une substitution à large
échelle et il a vouvoyé les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables qui excite tout
le monde a en rose donc ça c'est le
cumul de photovoltaïque éolien machin
etc alors moi je veux bien que ça
remplace tout ça en 30 ans dans un monde
dans lequel le pib aura doublé c'est à
dire la quantité totale d'énergie qu'on
utilise aura doublé quelques doutes en
fait j'ai tellement de doutes que je
suis même prêt à prendre les paris avec
les gens qui sont d'accord pour les
prendre donc sur le fait qu'on va pas y
arriver
donc donc le
voilà vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui les
énergies renouvelables elles prennent
plus de place dans le journal que dans
la vraie vie mais bon c'est normal le
journal nous parle de ce qui nous vaut
et de ski de ce que le journal comprend
pas nécessairement pas ce qui est
important
quand je regarde la variation la
quantité d'énergie utilisée dans le
monde sur les vingt dernières années
vous voyez ce qui a le plus augmenté de
très loin c'est le charbon puis le gaz
et le pétrole le charbon a augmenté sept
fois plus que le solaire sont les vingt
dernières années je vous laisse lire le
reste donc en fait ce qui s'est passé
sur les 20 dernières années c'est
peut-être l'essor des nerfs mais c'est
encore plus l'essor du charbon et du gaz
ça continue
c'est notamment dû à l'essor de la
production électrique production
électrique qui a été multiplié par 2,5
sur les 35 dernières années en fait la
production électrique mondiale était
équivalente à la production électrique
française en 1945
donc l'électricité c'est l'énergie de
deuxième la deuxième moitié du 20e
siècle par ici parlent par excellence
avec le pétrole la conjonction des deux
a fait l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
ça vient en mettant en route plein de
machines
qui permettent d'augmenter la production
vous voyez ici les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables dans les sociétés aussi
avouer que c'est marginal l'essentiel
c'est autre chose et en fait aujourd'hui
à peu près 65 % au point un tout petit
peu moins 60 65 effet avec des
combustibles fossiles c'est à dire qu'on
brûle du charbon du gaz du pétrole
surtout du charbon du gaz pour faire de
la vapeur et avec cette vapeur ont fait
tourner une turbine c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on fait du nucléaire ont fait de la
fission fait de la vapeur et en fait on
étudie donc c'est des bouilloires
compliqué les centrales électriques à la
base
et c'est le charbon et le gaz qui sont
les deux premiers modes de production
électrique de moi
alors grâce à cette énergie comme je le
dis nous avons augmenté
le la quantité la production est la
contrepartie économique c'est que nous
avons donc augmenter les revenus puisque
comme vous le savez la comptabilité
nationale fait que la somme des revenus
c'est la somme c'est la valeur totale de
ce qui est produit c'est
au pib c'est à la fois la somme des
valeurs ajoutées donc ce qu'il produit
et la somme des revenus et alors comme
on a beaucoup augmenté les revenus
puisque on a beaucoup augmenté la
production grâce à l'énergie si revenu
on les a distribuées et il se trouve que
même dassault ne mangeait pas si poulets
par jour on reprendre sa formule célèbre
et une fois que vous avez multiplié
quand vous appeler monsieur dassault la
taille de votre logement par 5 ou la
multiplier même pas par 50 parce que
vous vous y retrouvez pas à un moment
faut s'arrêter donc l'essentiel de
l'augmentation des revenus a profité aux
gens qui n'avaient pas et non pas aux
gens qu'il y avait sur le siècle c'est
bien comme ça que ça s'est passé et vous
avez ici deux séries longues
très instructif de chrome se trouvera
qui vous donnent la part des 1% les plus
aisés dans le patrimoine des français et
vous voyez que c'était pas loin de 60 %
au début du 20e siècle et que c'est
descendu au moment des chocs pétroliers
à 15% donc contrairement à une idée
couramment répandue les inégalités ont
terriblement baissé terriblement baissé
terriblement divisés et ses essais
l'énergie qui a permis sans c'est
l'énergie qui a permis sa et depuis les
chocs pétroliers depuis le début du
stress énergétique ça remonte doucement
donc le stress énergétique il va
réaugmente enfin je veux dire dans la
société dans laquelle nous vivons et
sans se préoccuper de la situation il va
conduire à une augmentation des
inégalités
parce que ça sera le phénomène inverse
de celui qu'on a vu au moment de
l'abondance énergétique est alors dans
le revenu c'est moins marquer l'écart
mais vous voyez également qu' il ya eu
la même évolution dans un sens je sois
choc pétrolier puis dans l'autre sens
depuis les chocs pétroliers
alors autres autre élément qui a été
fortement marquée par l'arrivée de
l'énergie puisque les machines boss nous
on n'a plus besoin de bosser donc ici
vous avez l'évolution du temps de
travail et là il s'agit du temps de
travail par salarié donc je n'inclus
même pas là dedans je ne fais pas le
temps de travail par personne sur sa
durée dit parce que sinon ça baisserait
encore plus vite parce que je devrai
aussi défalquer les études des retraites
et c'est donc là vous avez juste l'effet
vacances 35 heures
week end j'ai envie de dire c'est ça le
longueur et le voilà que l'on gardé
longueur des journées
longueur des journées nombre de semaines
de travail et dans l'année et nombre de
jours travaillés dans l'espace et donc
vous voyez que sarah considérablement
diminué parce que ça a été divisé par
deux en un siècle à nouveau c'est grâce
à l'énergie
et là vous voyez les faits du pétrole
sur le pouvoir d'achat des individus ces
trentes glorieuses être en glorieuses
c'est l'explosion de la consommation de
pétrole + 8 % par an dans le monde avant
ça augmentait mais pas si vite là vous
avez la guerre et après ça n'augmente
plus en gros et ça n'augmente plus
depuis le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde en 2008 chez
pas le temps de détailler aujourd'hui
mais dont vous avez des déterminants
énergétique à l'oeuvre derrière ça
qu'ils sont extrêmement puissants
enfin ça à déformer la structure de
l'emploi
l'augmentation du tertiaire mais en fait
est une conséquence de l'abondance
énergétique parce que vous avez besoin
de gens dans le tertiaire quand vous
avez un monde complexe à gérer parce que
vous avez des flux physiques dans tous
les sens et ça ça veut dire que vous
avez beaucoup d'énergie derrière je
prends quelques exemples si vous
construisez beaucoup de bâtiments vous
avez besoin de beaucoup de gens pour
accorder des crédits immobiliers si
donald atteindre industrie de la
construction tombe à zéro eh bien les
gens qui accordent des crédits
immobiliers dans le neuf dans les
banques y en a plus des gens dans les
assurances qui assure les nouveaux
logements il a plu si l'industrie
automobile tombe à zéro et bien des gens
qui assurent les nouvelles voitures
tombe à zéro et les gens qui font crédit
pour les nouvelles voitures en bas 0
donc et les moniteurs d'auto-école tombe
à zéro aussi et puis du reste les gens
qui enseigne aux apprentis comment est
ce qu'on construit des voitures tombe à
zéro enfin ouais donc plein de services
en fait disparaissent si ce flux
industriels sous jacent disparaît donc
en fait contrairement à une
idée couramment répandue
le développement des services n'est pas
du tout une manière d'économiser de
l'énergie c'est la conséquence d'une
société énergivore dans laquelle il ya
énormément d'objets à gérer et à ce
moment là gestion de ces objets
s'appelle des services et des ventes la
vente par exemple c'est dans les
services vous avez pas besoin de
beaucoup de commerçants si vous
fabriquez pas grand chose voilà donc
c'est le développement du tertiaire est
en fait due au développement sous jacent
de l'industrie et au fait par ailleurs
qu' à partir du moment où les machines
planté ramasse les patates à notre place
nous on peut devenir enseignant et aides
maternelles je la pose pas de problème
parce qu'on n'est pas occupée par des
tâches qui sont plus prêts plus bas dans
la pyramide de maslow c'est à dire plus
près de nos besoins primaires et en cela
je vais vous le montrer par des
statistiques qu'on peut qu'on peut
établir vous avez ici dans le monde la
part des gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture en abscisse en fonction de
la consommation d'énergie fossile par
personne en moyenne mondiale
c'est-à-dire les émissions de co2 est ce
que vous voyez c'est que plus les gens
émettre de co2 moyens dans l'agriculture
exactement moyens dans la culture et
puis les gens émettre de co2 alors ça
c'est vrai en moyenne mondiale de façon
visible mais pas extrêmement marqué mais
si vous regardez les pays qui sont dits
en développement la révolution est
spectaculaire vous voyez en l'espace de
25 ans la part dans la peau des marais
agriculture en inde a baissé de 20% pour
les actifs et dans le même temps les
émissions de co2 ont été multipliées par
trois
donc ça veut dire que quand il ya moins
de gens il ya quand ya plus d'énergie
quelque part on remplace les gens par
des tracteurs et par des engrais et donc
il ya besoin de moins d'agriculture
surfaces cultivables identique pareil
pour la chine et voilà maintenant pour
les services c'est pareil la fraction de
gens employés dans les services
augmentent quand les émissions de co2
augmente dans le monde et là je peux
vous montrer des pays à nouveau la chine
c'est très spectaculaire ou bien encore
le brésil mais je peux sortir ce genre
de courbes à la volée pour à peu près
n'importe quel pays dans le monde et à
chaque fois la joue donne quelques
exemples j'ai constaté la même chose
tous les pays où les émissions de co2
sont en train d'augmenter rapidement
sont aussi des pays dans lesquels on
s'urbanise rapidement le la fraction de
l'emploi dans les services augmentent
rapidement et l'agriculture la part des
actifs dans la culture baisse rapidement
dans tout paris ce que je vous raconte
depuis maintenant une demi heure ou à
peu près c'est que je peux résumer
l'histoire des 19e et 20e siècles de la
manière suivante
mère nature nous a donné des
hydrocarbures qui ont la bonne idée de
brûler et qui sont gratuits qui sont
aussi gratuit que ven je répète à la
formation du pétrole et la formation du
charbon et du gaz n'a rien coûté à
l'humanité pas plus que la formation du
vent tout ça est gratuit le vent comme
le pétrole donc ça brûle s'est
concentrée ça se transporte très
facilement c'est pour ça que ça a
supplanté les énergies renouvelables
et ça permet de grâce aux machines de
transformer tout le reste de ce qui
tombe sous la main tout aussi gratuit du
reste et de faire les dizaines de
millions de références que vous trouvez
maintenant chez les distributeurs en
ligne et de faire la structure sociale
dans laquelle nous vivons avec des
métiers tertiarisée où on travaille pas
longtemps et un surplus au delà de nos
besoins primaires que nous répartissons
comme nous le voulons donc nous voulons
alors un peu plus d'iphone et un peu
moins soupe populaire pour les
nécessiteux ou un peu moins d'iphone et
un peu plus de santé d'ehpad et de
soupes populaires pour les nécessiteux
voilà c'est décide en fonction alors les
états unis pays brut ils ont décidé que
la soupe populaire pour les nécessiteux
il s'en passera et qu'ils ont avec eux
des iphone ou des espaces privés nous on
est un peuple en est pas comme ça donc
on a un peu moins de techno et un peu
plus de care mais en gros c'est le
surplus au delà de nos besoins primaires
c'est à dire manger se vêtir se loger et
c'est qu'on attribue un peu comme on
veut en fonction des consensus sociaux
que nous avons dans les divers pays dans
le monde voilà je rappelle qu'on ne
compte que ça on ne compte pas le reste
alors cette très belle histoire se
heurte à deux limites au moins en fait
elle se heurte à toutes les limites
planétaires puisque la planète faisait
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre il
ya deux siècles de fait les treize mille
kilomètres de diamètre aujourd'hui elle
fera toujours 13 mille kilomètres de
diamètre dans le siècle n'en déplaise
aux économistes et au monde un fils y
est donc sur une planète philly
l'expansion physique ne peut pas être
indéfinie et elle s'arrêtera faute de
carburant ou avec la poubelles qui
débordent d'accord sur les placards sont
vite sur la poubelle débordera mais à un
moment ça va s'arrêter alors la
poubelles qui débordent c'est le
changement climatique c'est aussi
l'érosion de la biodiversité
c'est plus que les atteintes à
l'environnement le placard qui se vide
c'est par exemple
vous en parler sur les minerais aussi
jeu pour avoir mon bref là on va juste
parler des combustibles fossiles c'est
notamment les combustibles fossiles qui
peuvent devenir de moins en moins
accessible alors j'ai commencé par
parler du changement climatique vous
avez ici la courbe des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dues à l'activité
humaine depuis un siècle et demi lorsque
vous pouvez constater c'est que c'est
pareil vous pouvez mettre ce que vous
voulez là dessus vous pouvez mettre les
coptes vous pouvez mettre les discours
du pape ou la prime est ce que vous
voulez là dessus rien pour le moment n'a
infléchi la tendance de fond rien donc
rien
avant d'aller à la last night suivante
je rappelle qu'un gaz à effet de serre
c'est un gaz qui par définition en
physique à des raies d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge terrestre c'est des gaz qui
ont été identifiées il ya un siècle et
demi par deux physiciens dont un
français
l'effet de serre lui-même ayant été
identifiés par joseph fourier il ya deux
siècles
gaz à effet de serre il augmente la
capacité de l'atmosphère à intercepter
les infrarouges terrestre et de ce fait
il confine flux fortement l'énergie près
du sol
alors le co2 qui est le principal gaz à
effet de serre que vous aimez tant dans
l'atmosphère à une caractéristique à
part intercepté les infrarouges deuxième
caractéristique c'est que c'est un oxyde
et comme tous les oxydes c'est une
molécule très stable et il est tellement
stable qu'il est inaltérable tant qu'il
est dans l'air donc temps que le co2 est
dans l'air ilna le processus d'épuration
spontanée et il peut rester là
éternellement pour que le co2 ressorte
de l'air il faut qu'ils reviennent au
contact du sol donc le processus
d'épuration se fait uniquement au
contact du sol et ce processus
d'épuration il est double soit le co2 se
dissout dans l'océan mais c'est en gros
c'est un processus de vases communicants
il ya un peu plus de place pour mettre
du co2 dans l'océan donc il y passe mais
si un jour on retire du co2 de
l'atmosphère par dieu sait quel procédé
est à ce moment là le co2 qui était dans
l'océan ressortira pour partie pour les
semaines
passent communicant il ya un deuxième
processus d'épuration qui est la
photosynthèse donc la photosynthèse
c'est les plantes ça faire un truc que
nous on sait pas faire ce qui est cassé
le co2 en deux en utilisant l'énergie de
la lumière c'est à dire un photon doux
photosynthèse comcast le co2 en deux
gardes le cas garde le carbone en
oxygène à l'atmosphère et avec le
carbone et l'eau font du mieux qu aux
puits toutes les molécules ensuite qui
constitue la plante donc c'est ça la
photosynthèse alors comme le co2 est une
molécule éternel temps qu'il est dans
l'air et que le processus d'épuration au
contact du sol est un processus lent il
ya quelque chose qui est un élément
physique fondamentale du problème de
points que je suis en train d'évoquer
qui est le suivant qui est que après
arrêt des émissions donc un jour les
éditions s'arrêteront pas augmenté et
bien après arrêt des émissions si vous
attendez un siècle il ya la moitié du
surplus de co2 que nous avons créé et
qui sera toujours au dessus des têtes de
nos descendants vous attendez à milliers
d'années et à ce moment vous avez entre
20 et 30% des surplus de co2 qui sera
toujours au dessus des têtes de
l'humanité s'il en reste et vous
attendez à dix mille ans et vous aurez
toujours entre 10 et 20% du surplus de
co2 que nous avons créé et qui sera
toujours au dessus d'eux des êtres
vivants du moment sur terre ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est que
l'altération du climat que nous avons
démarré avec nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre elle est pour partie
irréversible jamais du reste du temps où
les hommes vont vivre est ce que si on
vit plus de dix mille en partie comme on
est en ordre la chance jamais du reste
du temps que les hommes vont vivre le
système climatique ne redeviendra
identique à ce qu'il était avant
commence à émettre des gaz à effet de
serre et à cause des conséquences un
surplus de co2 dans l'air certaines vont
s'arrêter rapidement d'autres vont
mettre beaucoup plus de temps à
s'arrêter la dérive climatiques que nous
avons mise en route elle est parti
maintenant pour durer des millénaires
quoique nous fassions
donc crois que nous fassions la
stabilité climatique elle est perdue
pour des milliers d'années
les hommes se sont sédentarisés et se
sont développées et se sont déployés
dans un climat qui a été remarquablement
stable pendant dividende donc la
civilisation dans laquelle nous vivons
est la conjonction de deux facteurs un
climat stable pendant dix mille ans et
l'émergence des machines dans la vie de
tous les jours c'est les deux qui ont
fait ça la stabilité climatique elle est
perdue ça y est il va falloir vivre avec
c'est à dire qu'à partir de maintenant
la dérive va être permanente ce qui veut
dire que ce qu'on vient de constater
dans le sud ouest est ce qu'on vient de
constater à new york c'est que le début
de toute façon il y aura car derrière le
climat va se mettre à dériver et le
enfin va continuer des rings et ce qui
est encore en notre possession on attend
pouvoir pardon c'est de limiter
l'ampleur de cette dérive avec un effet
retard dont je parlais dans pas
longtemps mais on ne peut plus l'arrêter
il faut avoir ça bien présent en tête la
neutralité carbone n'arrêtera pas la
dérive climatique elle en arrêtera
certaines composantes éventuellement
mêlera craint pas la totalité
alors c'est ennuyeux ces échelles de
temps parce que évidemment ça concerne
des processus qui vont bien au delà de
notre entendement je m entends demande
déjà une vie humaine c'est beau et
surtout ça va très très au delà des
patentes on a l'habitude d'avoir quand
on gère nos sociétés on collait pas de
temps une élection et c'est une
stratégie de long terme un mandat
électif dans l'ue de l'association tous
à ces quelques années la stratégie de
lambert dans une entreprise c'est
quelques années si elle est cotée ça
peut même descendre à 6 mois donc le les
packs temps qu'on a l'habitude d'avoir
en tête en ce qui concerne la gestion du
monde qui nous entoure son juste
totalement hors de proportion avec
l'épatant du problème à traiter
évidemment un problème alors vous avez
ici un marqueur de la dérive qui est la
moyenne de température alors la moyenne
ne dit pas tout j'ai fait une blague
d'aucuns pourraient trouver amer il ya
pas très longtemps en expliquant que ce
qui était en train de se passer aux
états unis en ce moment
en moyenne ça va bien parce que en
moyenne si vous avez la tête dans le
four et les pieds dans le congélateur
vous êtes à la bonne température alors
en moyenne ça va très bien aux états
unis parce que ils ont pris une sauce
est monstrueuse sur la partie sud et est
du pays avec l'ouragan ida dans le même
temps l'ouest suffoque sous la
sécheresse mais en moyenne soit bien
d'accord moyenne des 2 vient alors il
faut se méfier des moyennes
non pas que ça soit pas inquiétant que
la moyenne change mais en fait ce qui
les phénomènes extrêmes vont changer
beaucoup plus vite que la moyenne c'est
ça que je voulais vous dire donc en fait
la dérive de la moyenne marc une dérive
qui va être beaucoup plus rapide sur les
phénomènes adverse auxquelles nous
allons devoir faire face ça va être
beaucoup plus rapide et il suffit d'une
fois il suffit d'une fois pour détruire
une infrastructure il suffit d'une fois
pour brûler une forêt il suffit d'une
fois pour mettre à bas un régime
politique et ensuite avoir des années
des décennies de guerre il suffit d'une
fois
alors je n'aurai pas le temps
aujourd'hui mais il ya plein d'exemples
déjà le changement climatique à
provoquer des déstabilisations politique
des émeutes de la faim des guerres etc
ou à contribuer à
[Musique]
cette dérive climatique dont vous voyez
qu'elle était nulle en gros jusqu'au
début du 20e siècle qu'elle a commencé à
se marquer sous l'effet des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre dans le xxème
siècle qu'elle s'accélère et là vous
voyez ce qu'elle serait sûr au niveau de
la température moyenne en fonction des
scénarios d'émissions c'est à dire
combien est-ce qu'on aimait à l'avenir
et le scénario jaune là c'est le
scénario accords de paris 1.52 grecque
alors vous voyez qu en fait une des
conclusions majeures dont ceux de
l'arctique c'est que quel que soit le
scénario gouffre dès les 20 ou 30
prochaines années sont identiques dit
autrement la dérive climatique des 20 ou
30 prochaines années vous pouvez
considérer qu'elle est déjà totalement
embarqué elle est indépendante du fait
qu'on va se mettre à passer à l'action
sauf à ce qu'on meure totalement tous
demain matin quelques il ya plus des
missions du tout et à ce moment là
température se stabilise mais sinon
c'est pas ça qui va se passer et donc la
dérive des 20 à 30 prochaines années va
augmenter de toute façon
alors pour avoir une idée de ce que
représente une dérive de quelques degrés
et on va faire appel ou pas si voilà on
va faire appel à un passé proche ici
vous avez l'europe où les écosystèmes
installés en europe plus exactement
avant le début du changement climatique
et si on ne supprime pas ces écosystèmes
pour y faire autre chose et l'essentiel
du temps la suppression des écosystèmes
c'est pour faire des cultures c'est un
sac sa suppression des écosystèmes
ici vous avez l'europe dix à vingt mille
ans alors il ya vingt mille ans le monde
est au milieu d'une ère glaciaire c'est
qu'ils auront plus froid aujourd'hui
dans le cadre des variations climatiques
naturelles de la planète et vous voyez
que la géographie européenne ne
ressemble absolument pas à ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui en la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il ya pas de nécessité en suède
parce qu'à pas de suède les suédois sont
trois kilomètres de glace
de glace il n'ya pas non plus de
nécessité en norvège et en finlande pour
la même raison ni en allemagne du nord
ni au danemark tout ce bras tout ce beau
monde est sous la glace il n'y a pas de
nécessité à grenoble qui est sous la
glace et il n'y a pas de nécessiteux en
irlande et pas de vieux os en écosse
mais pas de rugbymen non plus qu'il n'en
est rien puisque tout ce beau monde est
sous la glace enfin non ça nous avons
encore plus en irlande les échos
funérailles de temps en temps pour
constituer c'est très très gros glaçon
voix l'ipad roman à succès en dix stands
pour constituer tout c'est très très
gros glaçon il a fallu prendre de l'eau
quelque part est la seule le seul
endroit où il ya eu il ya eu
suffisamment d'eau pour constituer ses
compilations c'est l'océan il ya eu un
gros transfert d'eau de l'océan r les
calottes et le niveau de l'océan a
baissé de 120 m il ya aussi les normes
calotte sur le canada était donc du coup
vous n'avez pas de problème de migrants
qui arrivent en grande bretagne en
bateau que c'est pas de manche donc pas
besoin de faire au tunnel non plus donc
vos parents n'y aurait pas perdu dans
econocom pas de break 6 pas de paradis
fiscaux dans les anglo normandes donc on
a un trait de côte qui ne ressemble
absolument pas à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui le climat est beaucoup plus
froide en beaucoup plus sec et vous avez
à la latitude de la france un type de
végétation que vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui dans l'est de l'europe en
version en version sèche et dans le nord
de la sibérie en version et on lui dira
sachets froide et à ce moment vous avez
pas beaucoup de nécessité en france
parce que la population française est de
l'ordre de cent mille personnes donc à
cette époque là les services
écosystémiques de ce monde je ne sont
capables de faire vivre à cent mille
personnes et pas plus
les services écosystémiques ça peut être
utile à quelque chose ça fait quand même
une petite variation cent mille
personnes et 70
alors quand on est passé
quand on est passé de
bombardements dans la région
quand on est passé de l'état de gauche à
l'état de droite en europe ça correspond
à un réchauffement planétaire et ce
réchauffement planétaire il a été de 5
degrés en dix mille ans donc là vous
avez le résultat d'une expérience
grandeur nature qui a été fait par la
planète sans nous dans le cadre des
variations climatiques naturelles et
vous voyez le résultat sur la
configuration sur la géographie d'un
réchauffement de 5° en diminuant se sait
sur les résultats il avait faim sur
l'échauffement a plutôt été bon
là en l'occurrence ont plutôt sympa
parce que ça a rendu les moyennes
latitudes cultivables et si en fait on
avait mis en route avec nono
plaisanterie actuels n'ont pas un
réchauffement mais un refroidissement
climatique de 5 degrés on pourrait déjà
connaître à l'avancé l'addition ces
quelques milliards de mort puisque la
totalité des moyennes latitudes
redeviendrait incultivables
quelques milliards de mort me paraît
être un bon nombre de vendeurs est ce
qu'on aura quelques milliards de morts
dans un réchauffement de 4 degrés en un
siècle bah c'est pas complètement
impossible
c'est en tout cas on ne peut pas
l'exclure au sens scientifique du terme
c'est pas le plus probable j'en sais
rien pour fêter probabilité dans cette
histoire sent pas beaucoup d'intérêt on
ne peut pas l'exclure on ne peut pas
l'exclure parce que quand vous voyez ce
que représente quelques degrés andy
bilan vous comprenez que quelques degrés
en ainsi avec l'appliquer à une
population sédentaire de 8 milliards
d'individus qui ne peut pas bouger
facilement
c'est un stress qui dynamitera toutes
les structures stables y compris des
démocraties etc on va se mettre à se
taper dessus on sera la guerre partout
et dans ce genre de contexte évidemment
ce sera malheur au vaincu selon la
formule célèbre de césar et
voilà je ne sais pas quelle sera la
diminution d'espérance de vie de la
population dans son ensemble la
diminution de la taille de la population
mais ça sera probalement pas anecdotique
alors si je suis un peu plus précis
quelques éléments dans cette affaire ici
vous avez le nombre de jours où les
conditions extérieures
deviennent létale c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas se tenir dehors sans mourir
dans un monde réchauffé de 4 degrés par
rapport à aujourd'hui ça correspond
essentiellement à la zone équatoriale où
il fait chaud et humide donc si la
température dépasse 35 degrés avec 100%
mobilité vous ne pouvez vous refroidir
ni par rayonnement de votre corps
puisque la température extérieure est
supérieure à celle de votre peau 35
degrés ni par évaporation c'est-à-dire
transpiration puisqu'il ya 100 %
d'humidité et donc à ce moment si vous
attendez une paire d'heures en restant
dehors vous mourrez donc ça veut dire
que dans les pays où les conditions sont
vous êtes incapable de vous tenir dehors
quelques centaine de jours par an ça
veut dire que vous pouvez pas avoir
l'agriculture évidemment et donc ça veut
dire que les gens en gros s'il reste là
il meurt donc ils resteront pas là alors
vous voyez ça concerne un milliard
d'individus ici quelques centaines de
millions 1,2 milliard ici ça concerne
quand même 250 millions là pour le
moment quand vous voyez ça concerne
quand même un certain nombre de gens
alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ces
gens là bas ils vont bouger alors est-ce
qu'ils vont tous 30-10 ijet pour venir
chez nous non ils vont bouger juste à
côté ils vont se taper dessus avec leurs
voisins
ça va faire les hutus et les tutsis mais
il y en a quand même un certain nombre
qui de proche en proche vont bouger et
c'est tout ça va finir quand même pour
partie par arriver chez nous donc le lit
des naïfs que nous nous allons échapper
aux conséquences du changement
climatique et les pauvres seront priés
de s'entretuer entre eux j'y crois pas
trop ça va évidemment être une partie de
la réponse mais pas la totalité de la
réponse est donc il faut s'attendre dans
un monde déstabilisé par le climat à ce
que l'immigration augmente alors pour
cette raison et puis pour une autre
raison que celle ci qui est que
l'agriculture va souffrir dans un
certain nombre de régions dans le monde
et notamment dans les rets dans les pays
du pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
alors je vous signale que les pays du
sud à l'exception du maroc
éventuellement sont tous importateurs de
nourriture est en ce moment il ya une
suspicion de nouvelles émeutes de la
faim parce qu'on est de nouveau dans la
conjonction de 2010 avec un marasme
économique et à une inflation
alimentaire que les que la fraction la
plus pauvre va pas pouvoir gérer donc ça
va barder donc il va y avoir des
troubles et donc une partie des gens
vont arriver chez nous comme les syriens
donc il faut bien voir que l'émigration
est une réponse humaine normale alors
pareils à des troubles locaux et que les
troubles locaux qui vont pousser les
gens à essayer d'aller tenter leur
chance ailleurs il va y en avoir de plus
en plus dans le cadre du réchauffement
climatique
vous avez ici par exemple un graphique
du giec qui vous dit qu'à partir de 2,5
degrés de réchauffement global le code
couleur c'est que quand ça devient
violet c'est global généralisé est
difficile à gérer vous allez avoir de
l'insécurité alimentaire généralisée
dans le monde et qui va être compliqué à
gérer et ça évidemment ça va faire de
l'instabilité politique et des
mouvements migratoires
alors voilà je vous le dis pour le fun
comme dirait l'autre enfin même si c'est
pas drôle passé la moitié du siècle avec
un scénario en fait ça dépend pas
tellement du scénario comme je voulais
montrer tout à leur passé la moitié du
siècle les forêts du nord de la france 2
viendront inflammables comme une partie
de l'arrière pays méditerranéen
aujourd'hui
les phénomènes extrêmes vont augmenter
en intensité ça c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est bien documentée depuis des
années tout simplement parce que dans le
cadre du réchauffement climatique la
température au sol augmente la
température de la stratosphère dit me
démarque
j'expliquerai pourquoi il ya des
questions et à ce moment ça veut dire
que le gradient de température
différence de température entre la
surface et la haute atmosphère augmenter
ça augmente la puissance de la pompe
convective qui met tous les phénomènes
extrêmes en mouvement donc les ouragans
vont s'intensifier et probablement aussi
les tornades les phénomènes de pluies
intenses où vient de faire en france
exactement comme ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis à l'occasion de l'ouragan ida
où il y en a je sais que nos idées
c'est à dire que le rien il ya un
endroit dans le sud-ouest où le record
de précipitations a été multiplié par
deux par rapport au record précédent
à l'occasion des phénomènes depuis
intense qui viennent de se produire ce
genre de truc à se multiplier
le groenland a commencé à fondre
l'antarctique de l'ouest et à risque de
déstabilisation là aussi je reviendrai
s'il ya des questions là il ya un risque
de trois à six mètres de plus dans
l'océan mondial à l'échéance de quelques
siècles il ya un risque si m de plus
dans l'océan mondial l'échéance de
quelques siècles vous rajoutez la
dilatation de l'eau ça veut dire que le
haut de la fourchette de ce qu'on risque
à l'échéance de quelques siècles
aujourd'hui est passé à 15 mètres
d'élévation du niveau de la mer
évidemment ça va aussi faire quelques
réfugiés même en france parce que vous
avez énormément de villes qui sont ville
multi séculaire qui sont situés en bord
de mer l'océan va s'acidifier ça va
porter atteinte à la biodiversité marine
voilà il ya encore d'autres plaisanterie
connu parce qu'il y en a des inconnus le
ralentissement de la circulation
océanique à large échelle les
déplacements des zones endémiques de
maladie la dengue et la fièvre jaune
l'entraînement palu
maladie de la langue bleue pour le
détail
ça c'est des trucs connus aujourd'hui
dans d'autres
et enfin vous avez les stocks de carbone
qui était immobile dans le sol depuis
des milliers ou des millions d'années
sous forme de carbone profond dans le
sol où se forme d'hydrates de méthane
qui pourraient être mis en circulation
en amplifiant encore le phénomène alors
dans cette histoire il ya quand même une
chose qu'il faut bien garder à l'esprit
c'est que nous allons avoir avec le
temps qui passe de plus en plus de
surprises parce que quand on fait
grandeur nature une expérience dans un
monde aussi complexe que le nôtre sur
quelque chose qui est aussi mal connue
même si c'est bien connu dans les grands
déterminant que le changement climatique
la seule garantie que nous avons c'est
que on verra des conséquences qu'il y
aura des conséquences que nous ne
verrons pas venir la vence
donc nous aurons des surprises et plus
le temps passera plus et surprise
concerneront beaucoup de monde et seront
ample et bien évidemment s'organiser
face aux connu on y arrive s'organiser
face à l'inconnu c'est plus dur
donc il faut construire des systèmes qui
sont résilients c'est à dire qu'ils sont
capables d'encaisser des grandes
variations et qu'ils n'ont pas besoin
d'un monde stable pour bien fonctionner
voilà c'est désagréable à ce que je suis
en train de dire mais c'est très
exactement ce vers quoi on se dirige
ycompris dans les systèmes sociaux les
systèmes de soins etc il va falloir
penser la capacité à résister à des
choses qui qui sont beaucoup plus
violente qu'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
alors j'arrive dans la deuxième partie
qui est le serrage de ceinture si on
veut résoudre le problème ici vous avez
un graphique qui a été fait dans le
rapport du giec de 2014 alors je suis
désolé 2015 jeu désolé je n'ai pas
encore les graphiques du dernier rapport
parce que l'édition n'est pas terminée
et donc les figures sont pas à leur
place et donc à dire la pêche aux
figurent dans le rapport tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui c'est compliqué donc
j'attends que les effets de travail
d'édition pour faire ça et ça vous dit
avec des simulations
d'envoyer qu'elle se superposent que en
gros l'élévation de température que nous
on en 2100 par rapport à l'époque
préindustrielle on va dire des 850 pour
simplifier les choses eh bien elle et
c'est essentiellement une fonction
proportionnelle
excusez-moi ya la patrouille de france
il s'entraîne tout chez moi
c'est
c'est une fonction linéaire de des
émissions de co2 cumulé que nous
mettrons dans l'atmosphère donc en gros
dis moi combien tu vas mettre de co2 au
total dans l'atmosphère entre l'ère
préindustrielle et 2100 et je te dirai
de combien la température va monter
entre l'ère préindustrielle et 2100
c'est assez simple alors à fin
2020 en fait c'est pas 2018 il faut que
je change cette légende on avait mis en
gros de 1300 milliards de tonnes de co2
dans l'atmosphère et donc on a signé
pour un peu plus d'un degré avant je
disais 1,5 parce que j'utilisais les
simulations en fait ce qui s'est
vraiment passé c'est pas exactement les
simulations de 2014 c'est un peu en
dessous mais la logique reste la même
donc c'est un peu plus d'un degré en
fait il ya 1,5 il suffit d'attendre
quelques années et on va les avoir donc
malheureusement je pense qu'ils sont
perdus et si on veut se limiter à aller
entre 1 5 et 2
et bien aux incertitudes de modélisation
près il faut limiter les émissions à
quelque chose qui se balade entre 3 et
4000 milliards de tonnes de co2 alors
qu'on en a déjà émis à rebondir au
premier ordre de 1500
donc ça veut dire que il faut limiter
les émissions à venir en cumul totalité
de ce qu'on aimait jusqu'au à la fin du
21e siècle doit se balader quelque part
entre le tiers et la moitié de ce qu'on
a déjà émis
et si je traduise ça en vitesse de
réduction ça veut dire que les émissions
doivent se mettre à baisser de 5% par an
en ordre de grandeur à partir de
maintenant tous les ans alors 5 %
d'obèses c'est ce que j'ai eue l'année
du coc vide donc l'année du coc vide les
émissions planétaires à cause de la
décélération économique ont baissé de 5%
eh bien il faut réitérer cette baisse
pour ajouter deux nouveaux 5% cette
année si on veut être sérieux puis dans
les prochaines rajouter encore 5% et
c'est donc quelque chose que j'ai
coutume de dire c'est que le bon ordre
de grandeur de baisse des émissions
correspond à un kobe de supplémentaires
par an
c'est ça le bonheur de vendeurs de
baisse des émissions donc c'est dans ce
genre de contexte on prenait encore une
fois c'est pas le contexte calme dont on
a eu l'habitude jusqu'à maintenant c'est
dans ce genre de contexte qu'il faut
penser l'avenir des faibles c'est dans
ce genre de contexte il faut le penser
voilà ce n'est peut-être pas très
sympathique à dire et alors la deuxième
la deuxième voiture balai on a derrière
donc soi soit on se serre la ceinture
venir après parce que on veut baisser
les émissions soit on dit non tout ça
est trop horrible donc on va continuer
d'avoir des ehpad et d'émettre du co2 et
à ce moment je dis à sauf que on peut
aussi avoir un goulet d'étranglement à
l'amont et à la bombe c'est le pétrole
le gaz et le charbon qui pourrait être
moins disponibles parce que y en a plus
et alors en ce qui concerne le pétrole
ça a déjà commencé
le pétrole
conventionnel donc ce qui n'est pas le
shale oil ce qui n'est pas les sables
bitumineux tout le reste est passé par
apic dans le monde en 2008 celle agence
internationale de l'énergie qui l'a dit
en 2018 moi je le savais avant mais un
certain nombre de gens le savent et
avant en public le sait toujours pas ce
qu'ils font n'a pas parlé de ce rapport
on en parle beaucoup moins que de messi
alors qu'eux ils structurent la vie de
tout le monde beaucoup plus violemment
évidemment
que messi
donc c'est passé par un maximum en 2008
depuis sa baisse et ça va la baisse
s'accélérer à l'avenir tout simplement
parce que les gisements de pétrole à
force de pomper dedans ils vident et à
un moment quand on a bien trompé eh bien
ça sert la production résiduelles se met
à baisser rapidement mais voilà à quelle
vitesse ça pourrait baisser ici vous
avez un travail qui a été fait par le
chief project il ya maintenant six mois
à peu près
et qui a été piloté par trois
spécialistes de la chose puisque là
dedans on avait deux anciens cadres
dirigeants de total qui était à
l'exploration et à l'évaluation des
gisements et l'ancien spécialiste du
pétrole de l'eeie et le rapport qu'ils
ont publiées qui est disponible inquiète
en ligne sur le site du site project
vous dis que si je prends la totalité
des gros pays producteur dans le monde
sauf vous n'avez pas là dedans le canada
et vous n'avez pas le venezuela sinon
maryvonne
et bien vous avez n'est pas le brésil
voilà si les tranquilliser
tranquillement
mais ça concerne pas le rock et bien
l'approvisionnement pétrolier à la
disposition de l'europe qui va descendre
très très fortement au cours des
décennies qui viennent climat ou pas
climat donc de toutes façons on va
devoir se sevrer de toutes façons de
l'énergie va contrarier va se contracter
pardon et tout ce qu'on pourra gagner en
des carburants volontairement sans
ceinture ça de pris mais à mon avis ça
n'ira pas assez vite pour échapper à
quelque chose qui s'apparente à une
récession structurelles alors je vais
finir par cette petite équation pour le
montrer
vous avez
ça commence par une identité cette
équation qui ai je dit que les émissions
de co2 sont égale à elle-même et jusque
là je pense qu'on devrait tous être
d'accord à droite je les diviser les
multiplie par la quantité d'énergie
qu'on utilise dans le monde donc je
divise les émissions de co2 par
l'énergie ça me donne la quantité de co2
que j'ai besoin de mettre dans l'air
pour avoir une unité d'énergie
c'est-à-dire une unité de transformation
du monde et ensuite je divise elle
multiplie par le pib c'est à dire que là
je faire paraître un terme qui est
combien j'ai besoin de transformer le
monde pour avoir une unité de valeur
ajoutée
donc ce que je viens d'écrire c'est ça
des émissions de gaz carbonique c'est le
contenu en gaz carbonique de l'énergie
fois l'intensité énergétique de
l'économie
alors les émissions de gaz carbonique
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut les / au
moins trois d'ici à 2050 et toute façon
un jour ça sera le cas parce qu'à cause
de la déplétion des combustibles
fossiles alors bien évidemment le
réflexe tout le monde la population les
politiques c'est-à-dire au secours les
ingénieurs faites-moi de l'énergie sans
carbone renouvelable et machin etc et
faites-moi de l'économie efficace
remplacer mois ces camions qui pue et
qui polluent bart de wever de
l'information
alors si on regarde dans le passé
comment ça évolue vous vous rendez
compte que la quantité d'énergie par
unité de pib les baisses effectivement
passé mais sur les vingt dernières
années elle s'est mise à baisser plutôt
moins vite qu'avant et en fait la
vitesse à laquelle elles baissent me
permet absolument pas d'envisager rien
qu'avec ce terme là une contribution
dominante à la division par trois donc
il devrait faire moins 67 % en 30 ans
bien d'accord avec moi alors que là si
je prolonge le rythme de baisse et bien
j'obtiens -15%
pas çà suffit pas on va très bien on va
s'occuper de faire vernon valable etc et
alors là c'est pire encore quand vous
regardez la vitesse à laquelle baisse le
contenu carbone de l'énergie c'est
imperceptible et en fait sur les vingt
dernières années sa baisse encore moins
que sur les années qui ont précédé
donc ça baisse vraiment pas vite et là
c'est pareil si je prolonge le rythme de
baisse j'obtiens aller 5% de baisse donc
je dois faire moins 67 l'âge et obtenu -
15 là j'ai obtenu moins 5 donc je fais
moins 20 se sait qu'on n'ajoute pas les
pourcentages le peu importe et donc ça
veut dire que si je veux être sérieux je
fais moins 40% là dessus
du sud est matin c'est juste des maths
alors l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
on passera pas au renouvelable vais pas
fait de grands développements là dedans
c'est que les renouvelables il faut bien
comprendre que c'est le monde dont on
sort le monde a été 100 % renouvelable
depuis l'apparition des hommes jusqu'à
les deux siècles sans qu'on s'en remet
aux blâmes et donc la question qu'il
faut que chacun se pose c'est s'il est
renouvelable sont si merveilleuse et les
fossiles si kaka berck comment expliquer
que historiquement ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas du tout on est passé des
fossiles aux renouvelables et on a été
dans les fossiles pendant dix vivant
puis on est en train d'en sortir non pas
du tout on a été dans les renouvelables
pendant toute votre vie sauf sur les
deux derniers siècles on s'est collé
dans les fossiles tant que vous n'êtes
pas capables de répondre à cette
question vous n'êtes pas capables de
spéculer sur la place des renouvelables
dans le mix futur
hortefeux n'est pas capable cette
question vous ne savez pas répondre à la
question des renouvelables dans le mix
futurs artistes voilà et
malheureusement je ne suis pas le seul à
vous à vous dire ce genre de choses
désagréables une des institutions
officielles de l'union qui est l'agencé
européenne de l'environnement qui est
une institution tout aussi officiel que
la cour de justice
où le parlement a publié au début
janvier un
rapport qui s'appelle comme vous pouvez
le voir la croissance sans la croissance
économique alors en fait c'est la fin
qui compte le début pas tellement dans
lequel il explique que exactement ce que
je voulais dire c'est à dire que la
croissance économique elle est
étroitement associée à l'augmentation de
la production de la consommation et
d'utilisation des ressources
et qu' il est improbable alors vous
savez quand une quand une institution
officielle dit il est improbable vous
traduisez ça en bon français pas j'y
crois pas une seconde ça c'est ça que ça
veut dire il est improbable que nous
ayons un découplage absolue et durable
de la croissance économique avec la
pression environnementale
c'est très clair ça veut dire la
croissance verte au moment où madame von
der leyen dit on va faire de la
croissance verte l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement dit non vous n'aurez pas
de croissance verte vous serez derrière
sans croissance vous aurez de la
croissance pas verte tendant à temps
parce que les arbres ne montent pas
jusqu'au ciel et que comme la croissance
économique c'est la croissance des flux
physiques de toute façon à un moment ou
un autre ça s'inverse donc de toute
façon et je dis pas ça parce que elles
m'ont fait une crise d'adolescence
carabine et de toute façon
malheureusement mes enfants vivront une
large partie de leur vie dans un monde
qui sera plutôt en contraction
économique que en croissance économique
c'est comme ça je vais faire ce que je
peux pour que adoucir leur peine mais
c'est bien ça qui va se passer ici dans
ce monde là qu'il faut penser y compris
nos mécanismes de solidarité et la façon
de penser les plaies de ceux qui sont
tombés voilà c'est ça c'est ça
malheureusement le cadre de réflexion et
donc je suis très heureux que vous
m'ayez offert l'occasion de vous le dis
vrai même si vous allez peut-être pas
trouvé
pensez que vous auriez mieux fait
d'inviter un comique troupier mais c'est
ça malheureusement le cadre de réflexion
dans lequel il faut construction voilà
et j'ai terminé
je viens à venir merci merci à 12,1
merci infiniment pour
cet exposé et cette démonstration
je vais juste passer la parole le
principe c'est que on puisse avoir trois
quatre questions un peu groupe et de la
part de la part des membres et de nos
membres sur après après votre exposé je
vais passer tout de suite la parole
dominique monneron moi j'avais juste une
question mais qui est un peu une
question bateau mais vous évoquez la
question finalement des esclaves
énergétique c'est les six ans et stella
énergétique qu'on possède chacun d'entre
nous et si on comprend bien ce que vous
dites c'est que finalement on va être
dans une logique où il va falloir
réduire la voilure
et oui on va passer on va passer à 500
puis à 400 milles à 300 voilà sachant
qu'ils sont inégalement réparties donc
au fait ça change absolument ils sont
inégalement répartis mais comme je
voulais montrer sur une des courbes en
fait ils sont paradoxalement moins
inégalement répartis aujourd'hui que
c'était le cas il ya un siècle d'accord
donc mais est ce que les politiques
répondre après est ce que les politiques
ont aujourd'hui
non non non là répond alors je peux
d'abord aimer si on est pressé par le
temps la réponse la course est
globalement bon d'accord c'est bien
alors peut-être dominique dominique
monroe
dont il ya quelques personnes qui ont ça
en tête et donc je vais pas vous faire
l'article mais je vais quand même noter
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
éventuellement regarder la primaire des
verts hier soir
vous en avait une qui a mis ça sur la
table de manière alors on sent qu'elle
cherche encore une façon de concilier
la chèvre et le chou 1 mais qui a posé
ça sur la table de manière très directe
est assez cru c'est d'un petit bateau
d'accord je l aimais aller marginal dans
le paysage politique français john styx
dominique monneron donc direct aux
vignes de de la fondation partage et vie
oui merci beaucoup vous m'entendez bien
regarde merci oui je prends la parole
puisque malheureusement je vais aller
consommer un peu de carbone après en
entendant une voiture
juste peut-être
deux questions
la première
est bien au fait que partager vie se
préoccupe beaucoup d'éthique
le monde que vous nous décrivez est
probablement un monde où les questions
éthiques seront des questions de
totalement de luxe et comme vous l'avez
dit ce sera va et victis mais ce sera
aussi très probablement malheur aux
faibles est ce que vous imaginez le
monde on a devant nous ne soit pas un
monde sauvage
et deux ans et deuxièmement pardon et et
je crois qu'il fait des coupes que des
questions est ce qu'il ya une autre
solution que
d'embarquer ma famille sur un bateau à
voile et d'espérer qu'on va arriver à
naviguer en autarcie sur les océans
alors naviguer en autarcie sur les
océans sans danger vous allez y arriver
pendant un temps et par ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est le système industriel
mondial qui fait les espars la voile la
dérive le gouvernail donc il faut prier
pour que vous n'ayez pas besoin de
changer quoi que ce soit à aucun moment
voilà donc le l'idée qu'il ya des îlots
qui sont totalement préservés de ce que
je viens d'évoquer
je n'y crois pas trop la vision
américaine où j'achète quarante mille
cartouches et je m'enterre avec 25 ans
de boîte de conserve j'y crois pas trop
non plus il ya un truc auquel je crois
par contre qui l entraide il ya quelque
chose que pablo cervinia bien expliqué
dans ses bouquins que j'aime bien
et qui est que en fait la résilience et
l'entr'aide c'est la capacité à
s'appuyer les uns sur les autres et donc
ça répond aussi à votre première
question qui est est ce que le monde va
devenir sauvage
c'est un risque qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour éviter qu'il ne devienne trop
et bien s'en préoccuper
donc ça veut pas dire qu'on va éviter
tous les coups ah non pas du tout mais
ça veut dire que si on ne s'en occupe
pas nécessaire nécessairement
la solution sera les régulations sont
plus violentes je vais vous donner deux
exemples si le pib doit baisser de 20 %
par an c'est pas la même chose que
d'avoir les revenus de chacun d'entre
nous qui baisse de 1% par an sera a
priori on arrive à gérer que d'avoir 99%
de la population qui conserve ses
revenus et d'avoir un concert de la
population qui passe overnight de ses
revenus à 0
d'accord sauf que dans les deux cas de
figure mathématiquement j'ai baissé de
1%
donc la question du partage va être
posée de manière centrale
c'est ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler les
quitter la question du sens va être
posée de manière centrale parce que les
gens acceptent en général de partager
quand il trouve que ça fait sens de
partager s'ils pensent qu'ils vivent
dans un monde non prévisibles dans
lequel ces démerde toi et où on a
l'impression que les gens qui ont en
charge notre destin commun soit se
foutent des problèmes qui nous arrive
soit traite pas les bons ce qui est pour
partie mon impression
est bien c'est évident que à ce moment
on renforce les réflexes de sauvegarde
individuel
c'est absolument évident donc dans un
monde qui ne fait pas sens et où la
classe politique n'est pas capable
d'avoir un discours adultes sur ce que
je viens d'évoquer on va au devant d'une
augmentation des tensions
qui est évident
parce que les sont pas si cons et et
qu'ils comprennent bien qu'il ya des
problèmes qu'on est en train de passer à
prester qui les inquiète par ailleurs
pas juste que j'ai évoqué assez
largement alors merci je crois que
thibaud de saint blancard avait levé la
main
beaucoup thierry est bon soir jean-marc
moi je vous suis depuis un certain temps
que j'avais déjà entendu une partie de
votre discours est malheureusement je
n'ai pas été étonné évidemment je suis
plutôt en phase dans les dents les
greens dans ce que vous dites après mon
sac quand j'entends ce que vous dites
mon réflexe en tant qu'homme c'est
essayer de chercher
des solutions
et c'est vrai que
les corrélations entre le votation du
pib la consommation de co2 après quand
tu vois dans le détail des secteurs
c'est ça paraît assez assez probable
qu'il ya des secteurs qui qu'ils soient
moins consommateurs que d'autres pardon
et en l'occurrence les nôtres
des secteurs du lien des acteurs de
l'économie de la vie comme comme le
signifie qu'un catholique
est ce que ce que ce que je pense du
coup enfin c'est hélas se fout de vous
je voulais plus pas de vous partager une
réflexion aucune question mais carrément
vrai enjeu à m des secteurs comme les
nôtres en avant des secteurs du lien en
avant
parce que c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
secteurs qui répondra qu'il réponde à
nos besoins des plus importants sierre
aujourd'hui l'homme où on consomme on
crée du lien on va dire si je peux avoir
c'est un raccourci
créer du lien et être en lire les
dessins avec les autres c'était moins
consommateur en co2 que de consommer
donc voilà j'ai eu moi ce que ça me
donne envie de faire c'est de c'est
d'essayer de convaincre les essayer de
témoigner autour de moi autour de nous
pour dire que voilà les allées des
métiers qui est des pans entiers qui
consomment moins et
fatigue qui peuvent nous faire
progresser
oui je suis assez en phase avec ça alors
le lien ici il peut se créer de plein de
manières les gangs des cités c'est une
façon de créer du lien donc oui on a on
a on a besoin devient alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est que si on se tourne vers
le monde du passé qui était un monde
sobres en énergie dans le monde du passé
sobres en énergie il y avait une
multinationale et qui s'occupait
justement du lien c'est l église
l'église c'est la seule multinationale
véritable qu'il y avait il ya dix
siècles
et les bobos log c'est-à-dire l'écurie
faisait partie des gens qui étaient bien
traités par la société donc le donc je
pense qu'effectivement il ya moyen de
moyenner
les autres et que de s'occuper du lien
et probablement quelque chose qui peut
être reconnue comme ayant beaucoup de
valeurs et ses 13 ans pardon pour la
répétition du mot mais c'est très en
lien avec ce que je disais juste avant
qu'ils aient que l'entr'aide dans le
monde difficile est quelque chose qui a
de la valeur
et le lien sacré de l'entr'aide enfin je
veux dire c'est de deux manières de un
peu de tourner autour de autour de la
même chose
donc oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le fait que de s'occuper du lien
c'est important et que c'est
probablement beaucoup plus urgent que de
s'occuper de la singer
merci annie chapelier peut-être voulait
dire un mot
pardon merci monsieur les néo z oui
monsieur jancovici vous avez à plusieurs
reprises parlé des politiques des
personnes matures et vous avez évoqué
delphine batho non non non j'ai pas d
immature on m'a posé la question est ce
que vous savez j'ai dit non donc
j'accepte de vous traiter d'aude
ignorants
des matériaux vie tiges
sans dire que j'avais dans ce sens je
suis consterné très régulièrement ce
matin même au salon des maires tous les
intervenants qui ont pris la parole
aucun d'entre eux n'a parlé d'écologie
n'a parlé d'environnement n'a parlé de
changement climatique alors alors que
lorsque vous parlez avec les maires
individuel dans mes communes du gard
c'est le premier sujet qui les touche la
ressource en eau le changement le
dérèglement climatique
les événements allaient cataclysme et
autres calamités agricoles c'est ce par
quoi ils sont touchés en premier chef et
pourtant ce n'est jamais au coeur des
discussions des politiques donc je vais
une peut-être une question à vous poser
je pense que vous connaissez
les travaux de sébastien bauler dans les
novices et son livre le bug humaine a
pour moi été une espèce de pas de
révélation nantes ou pas d'éclairage sur
ce qui fait que finalement nous autres
humains peut-être ne pouvons pas aller à
l'encontre de ce qui nous amène vers ce
chemin de la facilité vous avez évoqué
l'église à l'église quand même quelque
chose qui longtemps a prêché
l'intériorité mais aussi la dir
l'exigence dans la vie et c'est
peut-être ce qui manque le plus dans
notre système social et éducatif pour
que l'on puisse être capable de cette
volonté nécessaire pour changer de mode
de vie et donc influer sur ces
changements est en tout cas il est
certain que les politiques eux ne sont
pas est sensible à ce type d'arguments
sur cette analyse qu'apporter monsieur
blair est alors conditionné
alors de deux petits de petites sommes
éléments de réponse
plus un troisième donc j'insiste sur le
fait que si je dois lancer une
accusation contre vos collègues c'est
plus celle de l'ignorance que celle de
la deûle à
ça c'est fait c'est vraiment celle de
lyon c'est à dire celle de ne pas
prendre le temps de se documenter sur un
sujet qu'on ne peut pas traiter à la
légère moi je veux dire par là on peut
pas passer 30 secondes en six ans j'ai
compris ça y est maintenant je sais quoi
faire c'est malheureusement ça demande
un investissement en temps très
conséquents pour commencer à a
commencé à agir de façon pertinente dans
le domaine qui est le mien moi j'ai
l'air de vous raconter des trucs là
comme si je respirais j'ai quand même
mis 20 ans a semblé l'histoire que je
vous ai raconté alors pas 20 ans ça fait
cinq ans je raconte la même chose mais
mettons 15 donc c'est clair que ça
demande du temps c'est vrai donc si j'ai
une accusation à faire c'est celle de ne
pas de ne toujours pas y passer ce temps
c'est ça c'est ça le premier point
sébastien bonheur je sais pas si vous
avez lu le deuxième opus de la série qui
est où est le sens
alors moi je les lui avec j'ai lu aussi
avec brut plaisir j'en ai même fait une
recension sur mon site est en fait il
explique comment la religion a été une
réponse normale au à la sédentarisation
des hommes et l'apparition des villes
très intéressant
pas celle là
est justement il explique que à ce
moment là on avait besoin de rites et de
codes pour être capable de faire tenir
une société qui allait au-delà du nombre
de visages que vous êtes capable de
reconnaître c'est au milieu capable de
mémoriser limite limite au nombre de
visages vous êtes capable de métaux
regret quelques centaines et quand vous
commencez à vivre dans des sociétés
humaines ça va au dollar à vous avez
besoin de savoir faire la différence
entre amis ennemis avec autre chose que
la reconnaissance individuelle des
visages et donc on a besoin de code est
en fait c'est les codes qu'on reconnaît
et c'est plus les visages
et la religion a été ce qui nous a qui
nous a amené ça donc c'est très
oui je vois noël mamère je ne lançais
pas sur noël mamère parce que j'avais
pas être très aimable
[Rires]
le
parlant dans sérieux donc le
6 on si on en revient à la
question de comment est ce qu'on fait
monter cette préoccupation alors j'ai
aussi souvent coutume de dire que le
monde politique est un très bon reflet
de l'opinion avec 3 en décalage
donc il malheureusement il en démocratie
on est obligé de repartir de la base
c'est comme ça que ça marche donc en
fait pour qu'une préoccupation existe
chez vos collègues il faut qu'elles
existent dans l'électorat j'ai
malheureusement pas trouvé mieux alors
c'est lent c'est ça le problème et ce
mode d'action est beaucoup plus lent que
la vitesse à laquelle évolue le problème
mais là toujours pour parler des bons
auteurs parlent de baulers je parlais de
tocqueville qui expliquait que les
démocraties étaient des systèmes
languedoc par construction et que
c'était ça justement qui risquait de les
tuer c'est c'est donc face à l'adversité
structurelles de long terme eh bien elle
ne savait pas parler voilà donc c'est
vraiment ça
une des limites structurelles aussi du
système dans lequel on vit c'est 2 c'est
d'arriver à faire en sorte que la
préoccupation existe dans la population
façon suffisamment importante pour que
ça finisse par paire coller aux étages
aux étages supérieurs mais c'est un long
combat
merci merci beaucoup je prends une
question d'un spectateur est ce qu'il
existe des pays où des solutions de
régulation des émissions par la
contrainte sont testés au niveau
individuel une sorte de carte carte
carbone ça c'est une question
ensuite la parole à dominique bourgines
d'edf résidence alors la carte carbone
individuel est là c'est un système de
gestion par tickets de rationnement et
en gros il ya trois grands trois grandes
familles dans les gens qui veulent
limiter les émissions il ya ceux qui
sont détonants de solutions de marché la
taxe dont j'ai fait partie à une époque
et dont je fais toujours partiellement
parti mais je suis revenu sur mon
analyse de l'époque à l'époque où j'ai
écrit le pain s'il vous plaît
parce que c'est un système qui marche
bien quand vous avez des veseli devant
vous et quand vous commencez dans
l'urgence ça marche moins bien parce que
vous êtes obligés d'aller très vite à
des niveaux où les gens se sentent
désemparés et certains coiffeurs avec
une pression qui augmente beaucoup trop
vite compte tenu du dévoile donc la taxe
carbone aurait très bien marcher si on
l'avait mise en place il ya 20 ans et
augmenté de 3% par an c'est très bien
maintenant on a trop attendu donc ça
peut plus marcher il ya une deuxième
solution qui est de règlement de
rationner le consommateur donc ça c'est
le système de la carte carbone et il ya
une troisième solution qui est de l'eau
rationnée mais j'ai envie de dire
sectoriellement par exemple vous lui
interdisez d'installer des chaudières à
fuel ou lui interdisait d'avoir une
chaudière à fioul et à ce moment vous
traitez réglementairement un problème
avec une interdiction associés à des
mesures qui permettent à l'offre
alternative de se développer donc là si
vous interdisez les chaudières à fuel
faut pouvoir en place et sa part des
pompes à chaleur par des chaudières à
gaz parce que sinon vous ne repartez
pour porter dans le fossile et donc il
faut fabriquer des choses des pompes à
chaleur avoir des gens qui sache les
installer à voir des gens qui se gave
pas trop sur les marges et c'est donc ça
demande un dispositif d'accompagnement
de la puissance publique quand on dit
tel truc va être interdite exactement
comme si vous interdisez hollande suez
pour mettre en place des associations
anti-tabac qui aide les gens à se sevrer
il faut leur donner des moyens de
s'occuper leur faire faire du sport
pourquoi pour que les gens aient moins
en vue mais c'est tout un dispositif
dans le système de la gestion des
tickets de rationnement donc vous avez
un système qui est nécessairement un peu
enfin coercitif il est fait pour ça donc
ils demandent une acceptabilité sociale
à la bombe qui soit à la hauteur il faut
que les gens acceptent que n'ont pas les
ratios n'est alors quelquefois ça arrive
à force de leur dire c'est pas bon pour
vous dans le domaine du tabac plus de la
moitié des français sont favorables au
fait qu'ils sont interdit de fumer dans
les restaurants et que l'augmentation
avec les paquets de cigarettes pour leur
prix augmenter un plus plus de la moitié
des français sont favorables à sa donc
mais ça demande du temps on revient ce
que disais tout à l'heure parce que il a
fallu des années des décennies de
discours antitabac des médecins des gens
qui relaie le discours des médecins etc
pour que finalement les gens se disent
moi j'accepte que l'on me sèvres c'est
pour mon bien
donc là il faudrait que les gens aient
la même le même degré de conscience je
pense que malheureusement on n'en est
pas là et après il ya une difficulté
pratique c'est que cette carte carbone
elle est débité à chaque fois que vous
achetez un truc vous avez des millions
de produits achetable corps vous pouvez
acheter la chemise ou paulo que vous
portez là le truc qui est situé derrière
vous il ya le logo de votre association
pour acheter votre alliance vous pouvez
acheter une coupe de cheveux vous pouvez
acheter un micro vous pouvez acheter la
chaise sur laquelle vous êtes assis vous
pouvez acheter l'immeuble dans lequel
vous n'êtes rien que pour situer des
trucs qui vous entourent l'a
immédiatement donc il faut débité à
chaque fois votre carte carbone des
émissions qui ont été nécessaires à ce
que vous avez acheté alors il ya des ça
veut dire que en gros il faut rebâtir un
système de prix complet sauf que c'est
des prix carbone pour les millions de
produits que vous pouvez acheter
ça ça veut dire que la totalité des
chaînes de valeur qui ont abouti à la
production de ces produits doivent elles
mêmes tenir une comptabilité carbone
l'ont toutes les entreprises qui ont
contribué à la fabrication de ses
produits elle même tenir une
comptabilité carbone pour que vous ayez
exactement comme en comptabilité des
valeurs ajoutées tout le long de la
chaîne que à la fin vous sommet pour
avoir le prix
quand vous regardez le nombre de gens
qu'il faut mettre dans le système pour
que sa flotte en fait vous devez
dupliquer le système comptable donc vous
devez y mettre à peu près autant de jeux
autant de gens que ce qu'il ya dans la
comptabilité monétaire
vous comprenez bien que on va pas y être
demain matin
à ce niveau là et que par ailleurs rien
ne le garantit que les entreprises
américaines allemandes chinoise suisse
et suédoise se mettront en même temps
que les autres à la comptabilité carbone
intégral pour être capable de traiter
leur part de la valeur ajoutée quand
elles interviennent dans une chaîne de
valeur donc cette longue réponse est là
pour vous dire que on peut faire un
système approchant mais ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps et je suis beaucoup
plus favorable à titre personnel
maintenant au système réglementaire et
dispositifs d'accompagnement ça ira
beaucoup plus vite et ça sera beaucoup
plus efficace donc quelques exemples
vous interdisez demain matin la vente
des véhicules qui consomment plus de 5
litres au cent par une voiture vous
interdisez après demain matin et vous
annoncer ça aux constructeurs de
véhicules qui consomment plus de 4 et
demi
etc vous traitez les véhicules
électriques correctement c'est à dire
que les véhicules électriques 2,2 tonnes
voulait massacrés au niveau fiscal ou
les interdits à la vente et c'est donc
vous voyez vous ça c'est très facile à
gérer de manière réglementaire vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous avez besoin de
trois têtes bien faites pour bien gérer
ça plus une pour faire la pédagogie du
dispositif et c'est quelque chose qui
vous géré de manière sectorielle parce
que vous avez quelques grands secteurs
on mange on se déplace on se loge en
achètent
voilà donc c'est beaucoup plus simple
pour l'essentiel de ce qu'on fait d'y
aller de cette manière
plutôt que d'essayer d'avoir une carte
carbone
débité à chaque fois qu'on achète un
truc et puis le jour vous achetez une
maison vous allez exploser votre crédit
carbone de l'année alors comment vous
faites vous la mort tissé sur 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans 40 50 60 100 200 donc il ya
un milliard de débat à avoir dans cette
affaire-là et malheureusement le temps
qu'on les annonce à tous moments
donc c'est une idée qui était séduisante
en théorie et en fait quand vous
regardez les difficultés pratiques à la
mettre en oeuvre dans le délai imparti
puisque je vous rappelle qu'on loue avec
neuf cent trente ans en fait vous rendez
compte rond n'est pas le mordait pour en
faire quelque chose de réaliste
mais si je devais parler à dominique
bovina président du des présidents sa
gestionnaire des pages et je vais
glisser une question est prévu certains
débats commencent à installer des
panneaux photovoltaïques
il y en a qui viennent avec 425 que deux
sont
totalement autonome non non c'est un
produit financier
c'est pas du tout pour être autonome
n'ya pas de soleil la nuit je pense pas
qu'on va arrêter les respirateurs la
nuit parce que ya pas de se lancer pour
être autonome un panneau solaire
aujourd'hui c'est un produit financier
par ailleurs sa note d carbone
absolument pas le contenu carbone du
kilowattheure photovoltaïque en france
est équivalent au contenu carbone du
kilowattheure de réseau donc c'est ça
n'a aucun bénéfice environnemental zéro
doublé 100 et ça augmente les
importations donc c'est juste da c'est
parce que la presse a
relayé très fortement le discours des
antinucléaires qui disent de
photovoltaïque a que ça de vrai mais
quand vous regardez les caractéristiques
objectives s'il ya un truc qui ne sert à
rien dans ce pays c'est bien le maître
du photovoltaïque sur les toits
2000 bourgines
osant ce soit réalisable est ce que le
développement de l'énergie nucléaire à
l'échelle planétaire pourrait être un
élément de un des éléments réponse pour
atténuer pour retarder la dérive
climatique
l'arrogance et will et ses méfaits la
réponse est oui j'ai coutume de
qualifier le nucléaire de parachute
ventrale donc à parachute ventrale s'est
pas aussi bien que le parachute dorsale
ça vous empêche éventuellement pas de
vous foulé la cheville mais ça vous
empêche de mourir c'est à ça que ça sert
alors là le parachute dorsale qui
marchent plus et les combustibles
fossiles on doit s'en séparer et donc on
a besoin de trouver des trucs qui vont
amortir la chute puisque vous avez bien
compris que 8 milliards d'hommes avec le
pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes en
occident et c 'est les combustibles
fossiles qui ont fait ça donc si on
supprime les combustibles fossiles
comment on fait pour que la société
s'effondre pas et le nucléaire fait
partie des éléments de réponse sais pas
c'est très très loin d'être la totalité
des éléments de réponse soit aussi
changer les voitures par des vélos
électriques et manger moins 10 ans là
mais ça fait partie des éléments de
réponses qui vont permettre
si on arrête de se
manger la tête avec des faux problèmes
du lac léman avec des trucs totalement
secondaire
tout toujours pour rester l'un peut
alors vous avez peut-être trouvé mon
propos caricatural mais c'est pour
essayer de trouver des parallèles un peu
un peu illustratif le nucléaire c'est le
gouvernail qui grince un peu sur un
bateau qui doit affronter la toile la
tempête et si le premier truc que vous
faites sur un bateau qui doit affronter
la tempête c'est de retirer le
gouvernail en lyon où il grince un peu
si vous avez là pour les oreilles vous
pouvez s'est pas complètement sûr que ça
va améliorer votre situation donc là
c'est exactement pareil le nucléaire a
des inconvénients il a aussi beaucoup
davantage en fait les avantages comme
les inconvénients du nucléaire viennent
de sa caractéristique physique première
qui est que c'est une énergie
extrêmement dense
puisque hamas égale mise en jeu
l'énergie nucléaire libère un million de
fois plus d'énergie que l'énergie
chimique de la combustion je vais vous
dire autrement avec un gramme d'uranium
que vous fissionner en totalité vous
produisez autant d'énergie qu'avec une
tonne de pétrole que vous brûlez comme
vous mettez en jeu des toutes petites
quantités de matières ça al'avantage
d'être une énergie très compact
mobilisant très peu d espace que ce soit
au niveau des mines ou au niveau des
installations de production électrique
c'est très compacte
c'est besoin de beaucoup moins de mines
pour faire du nucléaire que pour faire
de l'éolien l avoir
et par ailleurs
c'est pilotable ce qui est un élément
qui est centrale pour un réseau
électrique puisque là vous n'avez pas
dit il y aura zoom avec jean marc
jancovici à 18 heures s'il ya du vent
vent en poupe avant parce qu'en face
vous avez un système vous appuyez sur le
bouton et l'électricité est là donc ça
ça veut dire que derrière la production
électrique doit être pilotable on doit
pouvoir la mener quand c'est ça le
contrat social qu'on a aujourd'hui et
dans l'ehpad ce que vous dirigez on dit
pas les petits vieux seront mis sous
respirateur s'il ya du vent passe à
contrat social on dit si on pense que
c'est nécessaire en fera donc le le
contrat social qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
que l'électricité est disponible à la
demande on peut revenir à une société où
elle est disponible quand les éléments
extérieurs on a décidé mais c'est pas du
tout le fonctionnement de la société
qu'on a aujourd'hui pas du tout du tout
du tout
il ya énormément de choses qui cesse
d'être prévisible l'information circule
quand il ya du vent il ya
donc le on voit bien que c'est pas
pareil donc
si on ne développe pas pardon et
l'inconvénient du nucléaire vient de ces
avantages l'inconvénient c'est que comme
c'est une énergie extrêmement dense
extrêmement puissante là où vous vous en
servez faut mettre ceinture et bretelles
et met trois mètres de béton pour avoir
la paix c'est donc c'est l'avantagé
c'est l'inconvénient s'il sait très
dense donc vous avez des trucs à la fois
très compact mais il faut bien s'en
prémunir là où ça se passe
quand vous regardez les avantages et les
inconvénients techniques objectifs du
nucléaire par rapport à ceux des
alternatives qui sont soit se passer de
combustibles fossiles sans vrai parce
que ronny renouvelables après enfin en
tout cas les roublards moderne
en fait y'a pas photo le nucléaire
utilise 100 fois moins de métal mille
fois moins d'espacé que le solaire c'est
donc la vitesse à laquelle il peut être
déployé est beaucoup plus importante si
on décide de s'y mettre avec sérieux il
ne remplacera pas la totalité des
combustibles fossiles on peut même se
demander si c'est souhaitable qu'il le
remplace parce que c'est aussi la
puissance énergétique aujourd'hui qui
fait qu'on dit guy les oiseaux les
insectes on bétonne partout et c'est
donc peut-être que il faut même accepté
qu'on est moins d'énergie quelle que
soit la forme d'énergie plutôt mon point
de vue
mais au sein du moins d'énergie plus on
fait de nucléaire et plus on abaisse le
risque global voilà ça peut paraître
étonnant de vous proposer cette
conclusion mais en tout cas c'est celle
à laquelle je suis parvenu donc dit
autrement plus une société attaque avec
sérieux parce qu'il faut le faire avec
sérieux en faire n'importe quoi
le déploiement du nucléaire pour
remplacer les énergies fossiles
et plus on stabilise la société parce
que moins on a besoin d'aller vite sur
le serrage de ceinture
que de toute façon on va devoir faire
équipe de toute façon on a commencé à se
dire va poser tout un tas de problèmes
parce que de toute façon il va devoir
aller très vite et de toute façon il va
aller assez vite voilà donc ne pas ne
pas faire de nucléaire en gros c'est
accélérer la vitesse augmenter fortement
le risque d'effondrement des systèmes
socio économiques
dans dans un monde qui va devenir
contraint sur l'énergie eia
merci beaucoup sont littéralement
explosé le temps le temps imparti
j'aimerais beaucoup que fin si c'est
possible n'hésitez pas à lever la main
mais aurélia le rooter geab
stratégie indéniable foncière
médico-social du hope action logement je
pense que vous avez peut-être des
questions mais c'est quand même des
sujets que vous transition écologique
transition démographique que vous
ça merci à cette intervention était
passionnante oh là là je sais pas par
quoi commencer justement le au travail
qui ont notre job c'est de racheter des
établissements médico sociaux et des
sites les de les retravailler de les
restructurer et de faire en sorte qu'ils
soient évidemment au mieux et
qu'on intègre ces
sujets à bas carbone voilà donc
effectivement on réfléchit pas donc bon
super expert technique je sais que les
équipes de maîtrise d'ouvragé travail
mais c'est on est très sensible à ces
questions on va faire la semaine du
développement durable sain 6% tirées
préparez d'ailleurs je vais récupérer si
c'est possible de récupérer l'âme cette
intervention pour planifier je sais pas
et je vous enverrai sup jorian support
oui bon en tout cas voilà nous les
questions c'est plutôt
bon vous avez dit oui au charbon et d
pad
de l'iphone va quand même triplé avec
les plus de 70 ans d'ici les 20
prochaines années donc il faut bien les
gens vont être en perte d'autonomie va
falloir les loger même si on fait tout
pour les maintenir dans les lieux
comment faut-il au delà de la
restructuration qui prennent en
concédant une écologique mais voilà
qu'elle soit une bonne technique pour
bien construire finalement l'essayer de
limiter le train empreinte carbone
ça s'appelle une étude
donc je vais enfin voilà il faut en
garder
d'abord j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle pour
vous dans les 20 prochaines années il va
y avoir des surprises
donc vous aurez de toute façon des
discontinuités par rapport à ce que vous
imaginez être l'évolution continue des
20 prochaines années je ne sais pas
encore vous dire lesquelles ni quand ni
comment mais c'est évident qu'un aura
donc et il est évident aussi que viendra
un moment dans l'histoire de l'humanité
où on aura moins de gens dans les ehpad
parce que ça ne sera plus compatible
avec la quantité de ressources qu'on a à
notre disposition donc avant on
regardait les lieux chez soi puis un
jour il veut des gâteux puis un jour il
m'aurait
je ne sais pas jusqu'où ça ira
alors je suis désolé de m'aventurer dans
un terrain qui est un terrain très
éthique et là je vais vous faire part de
réflexion qui n'ont rien de scientifique
qui sont des réflexions personnelles
mais je pense qu'on ne fera pas
l'économie d'un débat sur notre rapport
à la mort
je pense qu'on ne fera pas l'économie
d'un débat sur notre rapport à la
démographie tout ça c'est des débats
compliqués difficiles ça prend aux
tripes
mais je pense que tout bien pesé ne pas
avoir cédé la ces se mettre dans une
posture probablement plus désagréable
que d'avoir le courage de les avoir
et c'est évident que plus on met des
gens dans les ehpad plus en gros on fait
l'arbitrage qui consiste à dire je
dépense des moyens pour les vieux qui
sont en plus seront bien vécu il sait
les douleurs ils sont nés à un moment où
tout allait bien on a payé leur retraite
on s'occupe d'eux quand ils sont vieux
on leur a donné les congés payés on les
a baladés au tour du monde en avion je
ne sais pas si le
la fraction la plus jeune de la
population
jusqu'où elle acceptera que ce soit ça
notre arbitrage alors que ce sont alors
qu'on sait déjà gavés et qu'on en a bien
profité donc je suis en train de dire
quelque chose qui va peut-être vous
faire sauter en l'air
cc c'est violent dire ça qu'elle sert à
côté violent de dire ça je le juge et
enfin violent
sarah côté angoissant je sais pas
inconfortable voilà
presque dire malsain mais je pense que
malheureusement ces décès des débats
qu'on va être obligé d'avoir on va
devoir faire part d'un peu de faire
preuve d'un peu de courage aujourd'hui
je constate un truc c'est que toute mort
est devenue digitimes savez quand
j'étais jeune il y avait un truc
s'appelait mourir de vieillesse et on
appelait ça me revient que sa belle mort
donc en gros il y avait des gens qui
mouraient de leurs boys bord il se
flinguer dans une voiture ils avaient
trop bu et je pourquoi jésus était d'un
pont et puis il y avait des gens ils
venaient vieux et gâteaux y mourrait ça
s'appelait mourir de sa belle mort donc
à cette époque là la mort n'était pas
illégitime il y avait juste une bonne et
une mauvaise manière de mourir
aujourd'hui toute mort est il légitime
est une des raisons à mon avis elle l a
été engendrée par le corps médical à son
corps défendant probablement qui est de
nommer toutes les causes techniques de
dessin donc aujourd'hui vous ne mourrez
pds vous mourrez d'alzheimer vont mourir
de parkinson vous mourrez d'un avc vous
mourrez d'un infarctus vous mourrez d'un
cancer du pancréas et à partir du moment
où une cause technique
si les causes techniques c'est qu'on
peut s'y attaquer donc le la mort est
devenu quelque chose de normal alors que
je vous rappelle que si on est autour de
cet écran c'est parce que la mort existe
la mort est consubstantiel de la vie et
si a pas de mort il n'y a pas
d'évolution
donc le fait que l'on soit passé des
cellules primitives
bon on est revenu que nous sommes très
intelligents utilisant soum et bien on
doit notamment au fait que les êtres
vivants sont mortelles donc évolutif
donc le
je pense qu on est obligé d'avoir de
nouveau un rapport à l'abord
qu'aujourd'hui on refuse parce qu'on
sort d'amande confortable on n'avait pas
besoin de la voir mais je pense qu'il va
être nécessaire
je vois pas comment on va y échapper
merci à florence gaming général de
groupe bayard presse et puis corinne de
bain qui est
directrice de la fondation m de gaulle
et management de versailles et puis
peut-être après front bio alors des
interventions vraiment rapide donc bio
sur la précarité énergétique
ce serait ce serait pas mal
transgaming
donc le micro le micro
voilà oui monsieur jancovici vraiment un
immense merci parce que votre discours
et est incroyable on aurait envie
évidemment que tous les salariés de
l'entreprise et tous nos publics plus
puisse vous entendre pour pour se
convertir le plus rapidement possible
donc on est une entreprise bayard on a
une mission qu'on sincère de service
public d'une certaine manière on
souhaite avec nos médias notre presse
nos livres faire grandir les enfants
aider les seniors à mieux vieillir
accompagner les personnes dans leur
recherche spirituelle on a un
actionnaire qui ne nous demande pas
d'argent et c'est vrai qu'on se dit
souvent peut-être un peu naïvement que
en vendant plus de livres et des deux
journaux on peut aider les publics à
voile à apprendre à grandir dans leur
vie et accomplir une mission dans le
monde et agir mieux aussi pour la
transition écologique parce que c'est un
sujet que nous abordons dans nos pages
en même temps on est un acteur social un
accord un agent économique vous l'avez
très bien expliqué et plus on va
produire plus on va vendre plus on va
consommer du co2 alors comment on trouve
une solution en tant qu'entreprise parce
qu'on en a besoin d'être pérenne on est
dans un monde économique qui régit selon
les lois vous avez décrite comment on
fait pour avancer comment on fait pour
ne pas désespérer eh bien je vais vous
faire la même réponse que celle qui a
été que la réponse que précédent que la
première partie de la réponse précédente
en y passant du temps
alors je n'ai pas du tout l'intention
parce que
part j'en ai pas besoin parce qu'on a
suffisamment me demande comment vous
méprenez pas sur le sens de ma réponse
mais
le le métier de carbone 4 il est de
notamment
d'être là quand les gens commencent à
avoir envie de passer du temps à
réfléchir à ce qu'ils peuvent faire il
est évident que face à un problème de
cette nature vous ne vous en vous ne
pouvez pas vous en tirez pour vous en
particulier personnes avec trois
solutions presse bouton donc vous allez
devoir y passer 10 % votre temps si vous
pensiez vraiment fragrance est le vôtre
un personnel et vous allez devoir
embaucher cinq personnes pour s'en
occuper et ensuite impliqué la totalité
fâché non mais vous allez devoir faire
ce qu'on sait classiquement dans le
management quand on veut s'occuper d'un
prêt de nous et vous allez devoir d
investir de certains secteurs investir
dans d'autres accepte mal voilà vous
allez devoir faire ce qui est du ressort
du management classique face à face à
une situation
qui reprit qui porte un enjeu important
voilà c'est donc ce que je viens de dire
est trivial et en même temps
si vous ne le faites pas quelque part
c'est que vous avez décidé au fond que
le problème n'était toujours pas
suffisamment grave pour que vous ayez
envie d'attaquer
sur la partie tous les salariés d'eads
et des conférences qui ressemble à ce
que je vous ai dit dans la première
partie alors bon là je prends toujours
quelques exemples qui sont
circonstancielles
mais vous avez des choses qui ressemble
beaucoup je veux dire sur la chaîne
youtube qui porte mon nom dont vous avez
des enregistrements de conférences passé
à tire larigot et comme la physique je
fais un métier de fainéant physique
étant toujours la même je dis toujours
la même chose donc vous prenez n'importe
quel enregistrement intéressant et vous
aurez à peu près là à peu près la même
chose et puis vous allez le dire aussi
aussi ça ne coûte pas à liart
et vous allez le dire tous les matins
aussi sur manuel tous les samedis matins
matinale oui voilà c3 c3 là ça fait une
heure et demi qu'on est ensemble en
trois minutes on fait quand même pas
passer dans une quantité d'informations
c'est sur deux dernières questions et
parce que je vais pas juger quand même
de votre temps la commission leur avis
de deux dernières questions et puis je
vous laisse conclure
conclusion voilà donc que vous souhaitez
donc corinne bébin et puis francs bio
francs bio et corinne de bain comme vous
le souhaitez
par corinne demain
merci beaucoup pour cette passionnante
de présentation je vais revenir sur ce
que vous évoquez sur le débat
intergénérationnel oignons l'a vécu en
direct pendant la pandémie les discours
latin de la génération
des plus de 30 des moins de 30 ans qui
est effectivement le postulat blues
avait épousé qui était de dire pourquoi
sauver cette génération qui a déjà
hypothéqué notre avenir et qui en plus
est en train d'hypothéquer ça c'était
les vingt ans qui disait qu' en russie
potec notre présent parce qu'on ne peut
même plus à prendre et on t'aime même
plus aller à l'université
ça m'avait beaucoup frappé pendant cette
période de pandémie et lorsqu'on a
ouvert le centre de vaccination on a eu
une réflexion d'élus on s'est dit tous
ceux qui sont là bénévoles pour aider à
mettre en place de manière très rapide 6
centres de vaccination ont tous plus de
cinquante ans et ça nous a inquiétés et
on a lancé un appel et très vite on a vu
arriver les jeunes parce que la notion
de solidarité territoriale de proximité
n'appuyez pas les mêmes mécanismes
finalement
relationnel dans un cas on était sûr
plutôt une association politique de
masse dans l'autre cas on était vraiment
sur le lien
donc ma question est la suivante à la
lumière de ce que vous avez dit et de
notre expérience est ce que vous pensez
qu'il serait possible de quantifier à la
fois la consommation co2 qui a été
générée par l' usage renforcée des
nouvelles technologies pendant cette
période que vides et est-ce qu'on peut
dégager un solde de consommation co2
issues de 7 à la fois de la baisse
d'activités productives et à la fois de
la hausse de l' usage des technologies
et corrélativement est-ce qu'on pourrait
également dégagé
enfin avoir une idée de
la production économique que sagesse a
généré en sol de finale c'est à dire la
baisse
de production due à l'absence d'activité
et finalement l'augmentation quand même
d'une certaine forme de richesse par ce
lien sur le territoire nous on a
constaté qu' il y avait eu un énorme
renforcement du lien social et de la
solidarité territoriale de proximité
alors je vais vous répondre sur
l'économie au niveau mondial parce que
je ne sais pas faire là je ne sais pas
faire ce calcul au niveau français pour
l'excellente raison qu'une bonne partie
de la hausse des moyens numériques que
nous avons utilisé engendre des
émissions qui sont hors territoire
français là le serveur qu'on est le flux
le flux de données qu'on est en train
d'utiliser en ce moment là en voyant
notre combine sur un écran je ne sais
pas par où il passe je sais pas s'il
passe par un serveur français s'il passe
par un serveur américain s'il passe par
un serveur islandais ou je sais pas quoi
je sais pas où sont les électrons en ce
moment
et par ailleurs si vous avez à
l'occasion de la mise en place du
télétravail par exemple dû renouveler
des ordinateurs etc tout ça c'est des
émissions qui ont pris place en dehors
du territoire français
donc ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
au niveau mondial et donc la part comme
on ne commerce pas avec marc c'est qu'on
ne fait pas de zoom avec marc cela ça
prend tout en compte dans les deux cas
de figure la baisse des émissions a été
de 5% et ça ça prend nécessairement en
compte la hausse de la consommation
électrique du numérique la hausse des
émissions de fabrication des appareils
qui ont été plus acheter à cause de la
du confinement du télétravail en même
temps que ça prend en compte la baisse
des déplacements en avion la baisse des
déplacements en voiture et la mise à
l'arrêt d'un certain nombre d'industries
voilà si je fais le bilan global la
baisse d'émissions sur l'année 2020 dans
le monde c'est moins 5 %
la production de richesses
ah oui le pib mondial il ay le pib
mondial a baissé de pareilles 6 % ou 5 %
dans les mêmes tons
merci ils feront que franck bio wheel
ordre la production de richesses mais
pib comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure le pib
ne compte pas vraiment des richesses
puisque c'est un indicateur de flux donc
le pib c'est votre train de vie c'est
pas votre actif donc si vous dites si
vous dilapider l'héritage familial en
jouant au casino vous augmentez votre
train de vie donc le haut sens pib ça
augmente par contre au sens d'une
comptabilité actif-passif ça ça veut
dire pas vraiment donc
pib c'est le train de vie n'est pas la
richesse
bonsoir moi je dirige e franck bio
dirigeant fait une structure qui
intervient sur les questions de
précarité énergétique et du coup
j'ai un petit cas de conscience puisque
on est plein de gens en difficulté en
précarité énergétique à faire des
travaux d'amélioration énergétique donc
du coup bah voilà on investit dans des
matériaux bien sûr ça génère de
l'activité économique en bâtiment mais
du coup si je me demande en fait comment
on peut concilier c'était cette question
en fait du pib de production en fait
finalement de matériaux qui tu lis tout
un tas de choses pour des gens en fait
qu'ils sont en situation de précarité
alors on crée du lien on crée en fait un
meilleur confort et en termes de
résilience je pense que du coup ça peut
être pas trop mal pour ce que vous vous
avez en fait exploser par contre pas du
coup il ya cette question de l'économie
et du social qui qui qui s'opposent et
samara et du coup un peu presque
antinomiques en termes économiques
alors ça dépend ça dépend à quelle est
la situation de départ et la situation
d'arrivée pour les gens que vous aider
il ya quelque chose qui est bien connu
c'est que quand on aide les gens qui ont
un logement qui est mal isolés à isoler
leur logement une partie du bénéfice de
l'isolation va être affecté à une
augmentation du confort thermique
en fait on est des animaux qui résonne
de manière budgétaire
c'est comme ça qu'on raisonne donc joue
quelque chose que vous connaissez tous
là normalement la façon dont les
français gèrent leurs dépenses c'est
qu'en gros il ya par rapport à ce que
vous gagnez vous avez un taux d'épargné
qui dépend beaucoup plus de la
conjoncture et un peu de vos projets
personnels et puis tout le reste vous le
dépenser et donc si les lunettes et le
coiffeur valent moins cher vous allez
acheter plus de chemisettes basket
voilà j'ai on a une logique on est non
mais voilà on aider c'est de là que
vient notamment l'effet rebond qui est
que quand vous avez besoin de moins
dépenser d'énergie sur un usage
particulier vous n'allez pas consommer
moins d'énergie vous allez reporter
ailleurs
donc la question de la précarité
énergétique
je fais partie des gens qui militent
pour qu'on la traite en incluant cet
effet rebond alors ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas la traiter mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut bien d'avoir ça en tête
et donc
après ça dépend énormément de la
situation de départ souvent la précarité
énergétique à s'applique à des gens qui
surfent au fioul
si chez eux vous faites en même temps de
l'isolation et le passage à la pompe à
chaleur il peut bien augmenter la
température on aura quand même au global
fait une opération très bénéficiaires
pour l'énergie aie pour le climat donc
ça dépend de la nature dont classé il
faut il faut regarder en fonction des
cas de figure comment est ce qu'on peut
se dépatouiller pour que le
faire là elle ne pénalise pas j'ai envie
de dire
l'environnement c'est au moins ça
dégrade pas la situation
[Musique]
après les gens qui sont en précarité
énergétique sont rarement les gens qui
ont globalement l'empreinte carbone la
plus violente
c'est rarement des gens qui prennent
l'avion quatre fois par an c'est
rarement des gens qui ont une grosse
voiture c'est encore que ça ça peut
arriver et c'est si rarement des gens
qui achètent des fringues neuf tous les
jours donc
mais effectivement il ya un sujet à
traiter
qui est de concilier le sujet
environnement cette logique budgétaire
qu'on a tous et qui est à l'origine de
l'effet robin et l'amélioration de leurs
conditions
merci beaucoup à la dernière question
par notre ami chéries chéris qui
souhaitent juste une dernière question
on forme d'observation c'est qu'en fait
tout ce que ce que vous expliquez c'est
que dans un monde finalement on était
jusque là dans un monde sans limite et
nous on pourrait y rajouter dans le cas
des travaux que dans un monde sans
limite les personnes fragiles
vulnérables sont plutôt des éléments
limité parce qu'elles sont de faciliter
dans leurs mouvements et c'est donc elle
qui font figure d'intrus et le monde que
vous êtes en train de vous décrire et
finalement bhl qui découvre ses limites
qui se retrouve limitée et qui derrière
voie à prendre une certaine façon à
renoncer et les personnes aidant ces
gars là j'allais dire la figure de
l'intrusion se retourne c'est à dire
finalement c'est peut-être dans le monde
que vous décrivez qu'un nombre de
renoncement c'est peut-être les
personnes fragiles vulnérables qui sont
des experts de la situation je peux une
personne malade a prononcé une personne
qui est en situation de handicap apprend
la loterie a renoncé à chauffer le jeu
fait très court et est ce que vous
pensez que ce ce cop là aujourd'hui qui
consisterait par exemple et qui
permettrait aussi d'inclure des
personnes fragiles dans la société son
but mieux est aujourd'hui quelque chose
d'envisageable d'air d'enfer je ne sais
pas si on pourrait appeler ça des
éclaireurs noter les modèles
utile et permettant derrière peut-être
de fédérer l'enthousiame sur cette
question n'était pas un levier de faire
de qui exactement des éclaireurs de
faire les personnes fragiles vulnérables
les personnes malades les personnes en
effet
je prend complètement convaincu à
abc c'est une c'est une aile c'était les
questions là je sais pas je suis pas
complètement convaincu
[Musique]
oui on sait
j'avais deux grands parents
mon père était mon grand père pardon pas
de ce côté là a été ouvrier typographe
et ma grand mère était couturière il
sauf que c'était un couple de grands
parents qui étaient souvent
ils ont vécu jusqu'à
65 ou 70 ans
dans un appartement lyonnais enfin je
dirais très longtemps à lyon qui n'avait
pas de salle de la
donc la toilette c'était une bassine
dans la cuisine je crois qu'ils ont
jamais pris l'avion
il n'avait pas de voiture
bon donc c'était des parfaits écolo
départ fait écolo donc en fait les
pauvres son départ fait écolo c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui d'en faire des
modèles de société donc le voilà je suis
pas complètement convaincu que ce soit
si facile que ça
d'aller dans cette direction
je pense que alors après c'est vraiment
à une question de choix de mots ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la sobriété
au fond c'est de la pauvreté consentis
quelque chose que j'explique à mes
étudiants souvent c'est que dans les
économies d'énergie en fait il ya trois
ans il ya trois grandes familles il ya
une première famille qui s'appelle
l'efficacité et l'efficacité donc c'est
ce dont tu parlais juste avant
l'isolation des logements etc c'est une
amélioration technique qui permet de
consommer moins d'énergie à usage égal
sans se priver d'accord on garde le même
service un même taille d'appartements
une température à l'intérieur etc puis
on l'a fait ce qu'il fallait pour ça
utilise moins d'énergie il ya une
deuxième manière d'économiser de
l'énergie qui s'appelle la sobriété donc
la sobriété si on se place délibérément
d'un service et du coup on est vite
l'énergie qui va avec le service je ne
prends plus l'avion dans l essai de la
sobriété délibérément je choisi de le
faire mais de prendre le train à la
place je choisis de ne pas avoir de
voiture et d'avoir un vélo électrique
voilà ça c'est de la sobriété donc je
change de nature de service et du coup
j'ai aussi une économie il ya la
pauvreté et la pauvreté c'est exactement
la même chose que la sobriété sauf qu'on
n'a pas demandé mon avis
c'est juste ça la différence
donc le
évidemment par contre ça n'a pas les
mêmes implications sociales puisque la
pauvreté comme on m'a pas demandé mon
avis j'ai été baladé je ne triche pas
mon destin je suis pas content la
sobriété j'ai l'impression d'avoir fait
ce que je voulais et d'avoir maîtrisé
mon destin donc tout va bien et donc un
des enjeux alors ça se rapproche un tout
petit peu de votre question quelque part
c'est d'ériger en modèle de société
des assets ça reviendra ça quelque part
que dans l'imaginaire collectif on
appelle des assets et pas des pauvres au
fond c'est la même chose mais c'est en
gros c'est des gens qui sont heureux
avec peu ou avec des choses différentes
et qui vont faire comprendre que
justement le vrai bonheur est ailleurs
alors moi c'est un truc aussi que je dis
à mes étudiants le plus grand bonheur de
votre vie ce sera tombé amoureux ou
d'avoir des enfants
une fois de temps en temps ils nous en
font voir des vertes et des pas mûres
mais donc
je suis pas sûr que ce sera d'avoir été
le montre tel machin quoi je pense que
c'est pas ce jour là que vous aurez les
sentiments les plus intenses de votre
vie donc le le le je pense qu'il ya tout
un discours à travailler autour d'eux
qu'est ce qui compte vraiment et au fond
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
courir après des illusions de temps en
temps voilà donc ça c'est du ressort de
l'éducation c'est du ressort des valeurs
c'est du ressort des effectivement de ce
monde évoqué tout à l'heure du lien
c'est justement ça que très de bonheur
dans ses bouquins et il nous appartient
temps qu'on a encore le luxe de
maîtriser un peu ce qui se passe de
construire un monde dans lequel ces
valeurs soient positives aux lois aux
lieux conjoint entraîné parce que
malheureusement c'est ça le risque
concours dans un monde qui s'effondre
vers des valeurs de mort est négative
comme l'histoire nous a montré que
malheureusement ça pourrait arriver trop
souvent si ici on se fait surprendre
bien mais merci beaucoup j'espère que
personne ne m'en voudrais de clore ce
cet échange lever la main si c'est le
cas
c'est voilà à oui c'est le cas
mais je suis désolé il est 8 heures on
va poursuivre avec votre avec votre avec
votre arrêté de lever la main avec votre
accord
on va en faire on va en faire un replay
pour reprendre la main notre chaîne
youtube et on fera également un on va
tenter une synthèse une synthèse écrite
ou qu'on vous on verra évidemment corps
bien dans sa salle et certains écrite
c'est un exercice difficile
vous connais vous connaissez cette
blague d'autres chartier l'un qui est je
vous ai écrit une longue lettre parce
que j'ai pas réussi à en écrire une
courte
et mon épouse on est pas on n'est pas
les moins bien placés pour ce type
d'exercice vous nous direz d'accord
merci infiniment c'était passionnant jeu
reprend les mots clés commentaires
passionnants indispensable un
poil en bois sont aussi il faut il faut
aussi le temps dans l'acceptation merci
beaucoup beaucoup bonne soirée à toutes
et tous et à bientôt
merci beaucoup merci au revoir